e
good morning everybody it is 9:30 I'm
going to open
the uh
the public hearing thank you I'm so
sorry the public hearing for Senate Bill
420 um but before we do that if you
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
question
I don't have this bill in front of me
Senator I'm assuming that you're the
sponsor of this bill because I don't
have it in front of me just yet and
before I go looking for it I don't want
to no problem I'm recognizing the right
person right yes thank you okay
so Senator take it away thank you good
morning M Madam chair and good morning
members of the committee just want to
recognize I have a um ambitious intern
this morning my fourth grader is joining
me learning about democracy this is
Jackson you say good
morning um Welcome to the
Jungle for the record my name is Becky
whitly I'm honored to serve Senate
District 15 which includes the wonderful
communities of Bo conquered and Penacook
and hopkington today I'm I'm honored to
introduce Senate Bill 420 to continue
the work of the SB 251 study committee
um this is a committee that had passed
last year uh and we have been meeting in
Earnest um and I want to thank
representative re for all her hard work
on the committee um this was a
bipartisan Bill to take a look at what
is going on in our parole system um it's
one of the most productive committees
that I have been lucky to be a part of
um but what we realized is that the
issues are complex and that they require
some additional study we did produce a
pretty extensive report um which I
apologize I don't have with me but I'm
happy to send to the committee members
afterwards and we were just very lucky
to have have a lot of folks who came to
speak to us um from all sectors from law
enforcement to folks that have
experience parole to the parole board
folks um mental health folks the
Department of
Corrections and the systemic issues that
were raised were complex and you know I
think we really just started to scratch
the surface on what's going on um just a
a sort of as background um the council
for state government uh has been doing a
lot of work collaboratively in New
Hampshire to look at why we have sort of
a higher rate of folks in our our
Correctional settings that are on that
are there because of parole violations
it just we're just higher than the
national average and so the counties and
now the state have been engaging in
incredible work the Department of
Corrections commissioner has really been
at the Forefront of this to sort of
figure out why I would say that one of
the and representative Reed you know can
add to this one of the biggest issues we
identified as you know that adds to the
complexity of of course the entire
correctional system but the Pearl system
as well is that our correctional system
has become the place where we are
treating the mental health and substance
misuse crisis we are spending Millions
upon millions of dollars to treat folks
in Correctional settings um and that's
complex uh and it's expensive and so um
and the PE system is just a piece of
that um so that is uh a part of the
puzzle that we continue to want to work
on um we also thought it was important
to continue this work because the
council for state government has been
working with the governor's commission
advisory Commission on mental illness in
the correction system but it's the
governor's commission and the committee
members felt like we needed to continue
that legislative oversight of this work
in Partnership and that was also a
suggestion of the Department of
Corrections to continue that leg
legislative involvement so essentially
what this bill does is just keep the
committee alive requires an additional
report and then repeals it um it was
important because the last bill did not
have a repeal it was sort of unclear um
it is nice to have an end date on these
things so it just extends it one more
year I'm happy to take any questions um
uh and representative Reed can also sort
of speak to the effectiveness of the
committee thank you so much for your
consideration any
questions
just a comment um we worked uh it was an
all summer um you know uh committee and
Jonah was on it as well and that was the
Prime driver of our problems faced is
the mental health and substance abuse so
I agree you
know see you no further questions thank
you Senator thank you Mr
chair anyone else wishing to testify on
this bill who wasn't filled out a card
seeing none I he by close public hearing
o00
e
m
you
know
I'm here by opening the public hearing
on S SP 418 and I recognize Senator
Ganon to introduce his Bill thank you
for having me this morning
um I am Senator Bill Ganon I represent
District 23 the center of the wine
District it's 12 beautiful towns
surrounding Sandown I'll spare the name
of the other names of the other
11 um I come to you today with SB 418 it
was a change from my original
bill um and we'll stay away from that
the original one I did want to test for
THC limits because we're having a lot of
driving problems um people are aware
that it's very hard to test for THC we
have to bring Specialists um but that's
a bill for next year um I spoke to
commissioner Edwards and we amended this
bill and now it is um about increasing
the length of suspension for refusing
chemical tests of um intoxication when
arrested for violation of New Hampshire
driving
uh the bill is amended gives the judge
discretion to suspend the entire
mandatory 17-day incar incarceration
period in favor of substance abuse
evaluation in compliance with the
treatment plan when someone is charged
with aggravated DUI having a blood
alcohol content of16 or more uh the
stakeholders again with the Department
of Safety the New Hampshire forensic lab
and the New Hampshire Association of
police according to the attorney for the
Department of Safety seven of every 10
people arrested for DUI in New Hampshire
refus a chemical test it's
unacceptable according to data from the
Department of Safety 127 people were
killed as a result of crashes in 23 even
more were killed in 22 about 150 and
2third of all the crashes that resulted
in deaths were alcohol and or drug
related so we must continue to be
proactive in New Hampshire to keep our
state one of the same safest in the
nation on the roads and this includes
protecting drivers on the roads and
pedestrians on our sidewalk um for me
personally um since I've been young if
I'd go out especially now if I have a
drink I'm very aware that I should not
have that second
drink and I think it and I probably have
not had an extra drink many times for
the last 40 years because I'm aware of
punishment so I see this as a very good
deterrent effect um I think uh assistant
commissioner Edwards will have more
statistics and data on deterrence
effects and that's about where I am on
the bill but again I thank you for
having me this morning and I wish you
all a Happy
Easter thank you any questions for the
senator seeing none thank you hold on
one one question yes
ma'am thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um thanks I'm just
wondering
how does this um interact with like
pleading the fifth do you know what I
mean like is by taking a test kind of
like forcing someone to well I I mean I
think the commissioner
will say again what I'm about to say
that um the law in New Hampshire is if
you refuse you're it's an admission of
guilt so yes you are you don't have to
take the test then you're going to get
the consequences that's the laws we've
had on the books for long as I can
remember thank you and just for
clarification the Fifth Amendment
wouldn't apply necessarily unless you
were in custody and also where this is a
privilege to drive not a right so it
gets there's a there's a Nuance in that
is
who's
Moses I can just add to that it's called
implied consent yeah which is what you
give when you get a driver's license
it's implied consent that you'll take
difference good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee um appreciate the opportunity
to be
here um I'm here uh in behalf of the New
Hampshire criminal defense lawyers
committee and I'm here to testify in
opposition to the proposed amended
bill with regard to increased penalties
for the
ALS um I'm not going to have any real
comments to make about the changes in
the aggravated DWI law um but more so
the more so the Al and in the uh four or
five minutes that I'm allotted subject
to questioning uh I just have um three
points I want to make if I if I may the
first is that the increase in the uh
penalty for refusing to submit to a
chemical test is um very very close to
something which would have a Draconian
effect on many citizens in New
Hampshire um there are my understanding
is there are
approximately 9 to 10,000 DWI cases per
year uh my practice which is located in
Amherst New Hampshire predominantly
deals with these situations and I've
been doing it as you can probably tell
by my less than youthful appearance for
a number of
years um representative Manion and I
have done some business in the past when
he prosecuted for the pelm
PD um and so he knows that I've been
around for a while the the problem is
that the a first offender particularly
somebody with no prior record of any
kind or any history um of alcohol um
offenses or
interaction when they have their license
taken away for a year uh that has
tremendous collateral damage potential
people lose jobs jobs are lost families
can't be
supported um
and houses are lost to foreclosure in a
time when we're all having some economic
difficulties as it is and and what's
worse is that even if the
individual um is ultimately exonerated
in
court um it has currently has no impact
on the ALS punishment so that someone um
could be and I've seen it many times
someone could be arrested for DWI it
really is not a case where the person is
impaired not with standing the Judgment
made by often somewhat youthful police
officers uh on the street and yet um
even after a an acquit or a dismissal or
in some cases prosecutors who realize
that the case really needs to be dropped
because the evidence is simply not there
the person is still stuck with right now
six months and the proposal is for a
year the uh enhanced ALS which goes to
now three years
um potentially is is actually consistent
with the penalty for second offense DWI
which is a three-year loss a license so
essentially someone who has uh refused
to submit to Chemical Testing and then
and is acquitted or the charges are even
dropped uh and who was subsequently
arrested and refuses again is subject to
a three-year loss of license um that
that kind of situation um despite the
intent of the statute which is to uh
somewhat quickly remove people from the
road uh sometimes a uh this bill would
have uh people removed from the road for
far longer than their conduct justifies
which brings me to the second uh point
of opposition and that is that the ALS
law as currently on the books and even
under the proposed
amendment does not like in many states
characterize the ALS process as one
which is civil in nature rather than
criminal the New Hampshire Supreme Court
in
1997 uh determined that it was a civil
process and therefore uh not bound by
certain constitutional constrictions
either under the state or federal
constitutions and yet they've also
decided
uh that even though the privilege to
drive privilege to have a license to
drive is subject to a hearings process
which has been clearly defined by the
New Hampshire Supreme Court as one which
is uh requires due process due process
meaning fundamental fairness now
when when we look at this proposed
amendment it needs to be looked at from
the standpoint of whether or not it is
remediate
or
punitive and why does it make a
difference well it makes a difference
because when one looks at the intent of
the statute of the process the ALS
process the intent is to quickly remove
presumably inebriated drivers from the
road but at the same time the effect of
it can become so punitive that it
crosses the line between a civil
sanction and criminal
punishment and this is one of and it's
very difficult to determine where that
line is drawn the statute as proposed to
be amended in our view is going to cross
that line because uh even if the use of
the phrase civil proceeding is accepted
and of course the courts do give
significant difference to legislative
bodies uh when it comes to to um
statutory construction and so if a
statute were to say this is intended to
be a a civil sanction courts will
typically defer to that our statute as
currently enacted as well as the
proposed amendment is silent on whether
or not it's civil or or
criminal only the Supreme Court uh
holding has what determined it's it's uh
civil now even if the intent is written
in as being civil the ultimate
punishment may be so
punitive that it transforms that civil
context to one of a a criminal
uh penalty if you will a criminal
punishment and that's what this bill
will do if it's passed as amended
because the sanction is so severe that
uh it cannot be said that it doesn't
violate the eth Amendment to the United
States Constitution
um I would only like and I will close
subject to whatever whatever questions
the committee may have if this bill is
amended and by the way um I I digress
just a bit we have a whole lot of people
in New Hampshire who have commercial
driver licenses a lot um I I dare say
that in my practice probably 30 to 35%
of the people I represent and that's a a
lot of people um I probably have 250
pending cases right now and many many of
them hold CDLs the ALS form that's
currently in effect um makes no
provision whatsoever as do almost every
other state to advise a CDL holder as to
the consequences of his
refusal and that in our view uh needs to
be changed now if it turns out and it it
won't be resolved until un L than until
this bill is passed whether or not it's
going to require the intervention of a
court to determine whether or not uh the
new sanctions under the amended Bill are
criminal or civil uh if it should be
resolved by a particularly an appell
court that it is a criminal uh sanction
then the Bureau of hearings who I
understand is here with the
representative attorney CCO a a good
friend and colleague whom I respect
greatly um they're going to completely
be out of business because the
administrative agency cannot sanction
people with criminal penalties and
that's one of the things that may occur
uh and may not have been foreseen when
this process was undertaken to amend the
statute so I would respectfully submit
that the ALS form with its fine print on
the back side side that almost nobody
even some lawyers don't understand needs
to be far more clear and needs to spell
out um much more what the potential
penalties and sanctions are going to be
so that a person can make an informed
consent which our Supreme Court has also
said an individual has a right to do is
to make an informed and intelligent
decision particularly since they're not
entitled to the right to counsel and
this comes around from uh from the point
I earlier made
that if it it's determined by a court
which we believe there is a strong
probability will occur if this amended
bill with its somewhat honorous
sanctions is passed um what has been the
law n since 1986 whereby people do not
have the right to counsel when they're M
making a decision about whether it ATT
test or not if that turns out to be a a
a legal rule that it is Criminal then
they are going to have a right the
council because this is as our Supreme
Court has said it is a due process
matter which requires fundamental
fairness and so um I would respectfully
submit that much more is needed to put
people on notice uh of of what what
their choices are what these sanctions
will be but this bill um this bill will
do nothing to help that unless along the
way the department of safety is is
tasked with the uh with the obligation
to prepare a clear and understandable uh
document which people who are being
asked to submit to chemical tests
um understand lastly it's been
established over the years that changing
the penalties for refusing have has not
increased the the likelihood that people
are going to take the tests I can tell
you based on my own experience that uh
vast majority of people don't trust them
they don't trust the particularly the
breath test particularly the breath test
and with good reason um and and
um and so given that even if you pass
this it's going to be very difficult for
for us to to Envision any increase in
the in the uh uh taking of a test also
the fact that the um sanction can be
reduced by 180 days if one pleads guilty
or noow is We Believe unconstitutionally
coercive and so we oppose the bill on
those grounds I do appreciate the
committee's time and I probably Ed up
more than the five minutes that I put
down but lawyers tend to do that anyway
we always we all excuse
me yeah yeah we Round Up by a lot
sometimes um
nevertheless if the committee does have
any questions I certainly would be more
than happy to try and answer them for
Youk if not I'm concluded thank you um
we have a few questions with regard to
this question um that seems to be the
Crux of your your opposition um with
regard to becoming a a criminal um
matter versus a
civil with our implied consent law in
New Hampshire when you get a driver's
license you sign a document that says I
I understand that I have to comply and
consent to this test and if I don't
there'll be there'll be
penalties and so they're increasing that
penalty don't so it's more contract law
than criminal and don't most contracts
have a penalty if you fail to live up to
the contract I mean they don't become
criminal when a when a company says you
know you have to deliver X widgets by
this day or you incur a penalty it
doesn't become criminal because it's a
higher penalty so how do you equate that
the two of those things well well
actually that's
to use your example that that's not
entirely true and I say that I say that
respectfully there are a number of um
for example your your contract example
um perhaps another example would be a
non-competition agreement where a let's
say a doctor leaves a practice and
agrees not to practice medicine uh
within a certain number of miles for a
certain period of time um those
contracts and the San that are imposed
uh can be so punitive that in under
contract law which I readily admit is
certainly not my specialty but based on
on my my recollection of contract law
can become um so honorous that it
becomes against public policy and
therefore
unenforceable similarly a non-cmp
agreement in the Civil context um if I
leave a medical practice un conquered um
and my and my non-compete says that I
can't practice medicine anywhere east of
the Mississippi River for a period of 40
years even if I sign that a court is
never going to enforce it because we're
talking about reasonableness in the in
the contract context the the thing that
makes it difficult um in this situation
Mr chairman is is that yes you do sign a
paper we all do and and and honestly
none of us not a single person in this
room ever wants to be driving down the
road and have a vehicle on our side of
the road except going the wrong way
because they've been drinking nobody
wants that um but having having said
that um the the uh the the refusal
situation is it gets a little cumbersome
because while it's true that you sign
and apply
consent the legis lure has also created
a
statute and that's it's statutory not
constitutional I and I could seeed that
point but the twain does meet at some
point or at least it has the potential
of meeting at some point and so um yes
you've impliedly consented to submit the
testing no question about it and as as
as a whole line of cases from the state
supreme court has said however the
legislature has essentially given
drivers the the statutory right which
could be taken away technically
statutory right to say no but as as the
court said and I I know citing cases
that's not going to impress anybody but
there there are a couple of cases out
there that say basically you have a
statutory right to refuse but it comes
with strings strings are attached and
those strings are first and foremost a
very rapid and potentially lengthy loss
of license simply because you said no
but then we have the line of cases where
the Supreme Court has not only
recognized um that you imply consent to
submit to testing but then they go on to
say very clearly that um the suspension
of a driver license in New Hampshire
cannot be undertaken by the appropriate
agency unless that person is afforded
due process and when one talks of due
process as New Hampshire has defined it
that becomes something which is fun
fundamentally fair not only in the
implementation of the process but in the
sanction which is imposed and at some
point it becomes fundamentally unfair
and when that happens it's very much
like a contract which is against public
policy that sole difference is when you
have something against the public policy
the contract is
nullified when you do it in in the in
the context of what we're talking about
today that's when it has a very serious
and likely uh potential of becoming
criminal which is which is really going
to uh turn things upside down and it may
not be something that the legislature
wants to weigh into and probably the
court doesn't want to weigh into it but
if this bill passes uh as is it would be
my
expectation um that it won't take very
long to get challenged that's that's not
something that I I mean to suggest I'm
not trying to be flip but but the but
the the very real Poss ility is there
and whether or not the statute uh when
passed is going to remain uh viable is
something I think that that this
committee needs to consider before uh
making a determination about its status
thank you with regard to the um public
policy aspect if it offends public
policy doesn't it have to be so bad uh I
think the term is so as to offend the
public conscience so do you feel like
the one-year automatic would offend the
public
conscience I I do okay and and and and
our committee does because there's no
you know if there was a provision in
there and far be it for me to you know
suggest legislative uh language but if
there was at least a provision in there
like there are in a number of states
where someone is subject to a
significant penalty which may be deemed
to be
civil if the person is subsequently
acquitted or found not guilty or
the case is dismissed or the state using
the the that arm of the the executive
branch of of the government chooses to
null PR then there certainly should be
something in the statute to ameliorate
the damage which is done by the lengthy
suspension namely uh the ALS at that
point should U should terminate thank
you um my last question is you brought
up the um CDL which is interesting the
the CDL um this would have serious
ramifications for their
licenses isn't the limit um what is the
what is the blood alcohol limit for a
CDL holder isn't it like zero or is it
02 it's much lower isn't it it it is
much lower it's it's um it is 0.004 04
however however what's important to
understand is that um and and that's
where some of the confusion Lies by the
way with the ALS form but I'll get to
that in a moment if you allow me sure
absolutely um the uh uh the federal
government under the code of federal
regulations has passed a number of
regulations dealing with commercial
driver licenses uh that was sort of
brought to the Forefront when that
tremendously unfortunate situation arose
in
Randolph um that that came to the
Forefront now New Hampshire uh has
adopted the equivalent of those cfrs in
addressing CDL Drivers here in New
Hampshire and so when a person who has a
CDL is driving one of two different
kinds of vehicles and it matters what
you're
driving a little bit more to confuse
these folks um if you are driving a
commercial
vehicle and there is an arrest made for
uh a
DWI the limit for CDL is
04 that's the law and we've adopted that
here in New
Hampshire
it is
008 for the legal
limit regardless of whether you're
driving a commercial vehicle or not for
purposes of the use of that breath test
in a subsequent Court
proceeding if you're driving a personal
car but possess a
CDL and you refuse to submit to Chemical
Testing by law the driver license
assuming a first offense under the
current statutory scheme you're driving
privilege your driver's license is
suspended for 6 months but your CDL is
suspended for a
year just as importantly a refusal to
submit to a chemical test by a CDL
holder regardless of what type of
vehicle they're driving is considered to
be a serious or major offense for
purposes of CDL
sanctions um and of course we understand
why we certainly don't need someone I be
pardon the um automatic one year for the
CDL and the serious offense that's under
the CFR is are correct it is but we've
adopted that okay and and the problem
with that is if someone were to for
example refuse but not be convicted and
then subsequently be convicted that
would be two serious or major offenses
and that's a lifetime suspension subject
to you can petition to reinstate after
to 10 years and that's fine if you're 32
years old it's not so fine if you're 62
years old um so the CDL and there's a
lot of confusion and I've represented a
whole lot of clients who have CDLs who
have refused Chemical
Testing not withstanding that the DS smv
426 form says
08 and I have a you know obviously
didn't bring it with me and and but I
can tell you I have a a body warn camera
video of of a conversation that occurred
in the case that I just resolved where
where there was a discussion between my
client and the police officer and he
said I can't I can't take that I I the
08 doesn't mean anything it's po it's 04
he was in his own pickup truck um but he
thought I have a CDL and they told me 04
no we have hands or butts so I I'm I'm
I'm over 04 but I'm under 08 but I can't
take your test because I'm over an 04
and most police officers with all due
respect tow enforcement they don't know
a thing about the CDL penalties and that
my understanding is I don't even know if
they're taught that at standards and
training during the the DWI training
component so it seems to seems to me
that at the very minimum there has to be
a change in the form whereby it says
something like if you are a CDL holder
then this is what you need to to do and
there are actually several examples in
States like Georgia Wisconsin and Ohio
where the form actually has paragraphs
dealing with are you under 21 do you
have a CDL that type of thing do you
have a prior offense and the person who
was asked to sign the ALS form
indicating choice of taking or refusing
a test also was required to initial an
an applicable paragraph so that there
won't be any question should there be a
challenge later on as to whether or not
they were properly advised of the of of
what sanctions apply to them thank you
representative Stone you have a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question as a practical matter in
your experience how often are ALS
hearings going forward these days or are
they negotiated way as part of the uh
resolution of the case
overall
um the the easy answer to that is a
number of them don't go forward because
the regulations of the DMV provide for
the withdrawal of als's under two
circumstances one is in exchange for a
guilty plea whereby a police department
although they're not required to uh can
submit um a letter to the DMV Bureau of
hearings in which they indicate that Mr
Smith pledge to a DWI in the conquered
Circuit Court um pursuant to this
regulation we would ask that the ALS be
withdrawn that's number one or there's
an error of law for example if someone
uh someone refused es um but it turns
out that the officer in the course of
administering the ALS rights provided
misinformation in other words it's a
second it's a second offense the officer
knows that the individual says well how
long am I going to lose my license the
officer says 6 months which would be
incorrect information that's the kind of
error of law we're talking about
um there is no and I with all due
respect to to attorney Casco uh
um there is no
provision at the Bureau of hearings
where the state can essentially null PR
an Als in other words withdraw it
without having to give a reason without
having to have a plea uh quite frankly I
think it's a limitation on the executive
branch that is unconstitutional but I
digress so to answer your
question I would say that um
a vast number of ALS hearings don't go
forward but that often occurs under
circumstances where there's a plea
negotiation reached on the merits of the
DWI case which results in a plea to a
lesser included offense or a less
serious offense um such as reckless
driving that happens with with a great
deal of frequency um so those those
hearings don't go forward but um there
are a number of agencies where
regardless of the outcome of the the
criminal aspect of the case they won't
they won't touch the ALS they won't go
anywhere near it it's like it's a
refusal you know we're not going to
withdraw it so those hearings go forward
I I have to say that in my practice and
in my
experience I would
say it's not a cop out but it's about
50/50 I it's pretty evenly
divided um in terms of those that have
to go to hearing and those that are are
otherwise resolved
whereby an individual withdraws his
request because of a plea agreement
reached in court um or um or the state
withdraws it um not just for a DWI
conviction but because there may be some
some error of laws as is provided for
under the regulations representative
Newman thank you Mr chair and it's just
a quick
question if this law were followed and
and a person were to ref refuse a test
does that then eliminate the possibility
that that uh that ple that the charge
may be pled down is how does
that I'm not sure respectfully I'm not
sure you have the administrative removal
of the license yes you you mentioned
pleading down to other lesser included
crimes is it what effect does this law
have on on that if
any none thank you
you see no further questions thank you
oh oh representative side not getting
out that easy I guess I I just want to
be sure I understand what you had said
and that is somebody I was under the
impression if you refuse it's automatic
no chance no uh discretion at all you
lose your license for six months are you
telling me that if you plead on the
merits of the case to the D DUI in court
found guilty
you can still appeal to the DMV to get
the uh ALS removed yes that I didn't
realize that existed yes the way the way
it works it because of the because of
the current APP pellet uh law in in New
Hampshire which is a case called State
versus Cassidy goes back to 1997 I
believe they're treated separately
so if a person plead
guilty and as part of that plea deal it
would have to be with agreement with the
prosecution because it's not
mandatory even though perhaps it should
be but it's not the person pleads guilty
the Department of Motor Vehicles has has
a regulation that allows the prosecution
to then cancel out whatever is left of
the ALS however however um if a person
goes to
trial
and is found guilty that particular
regulation doesn't apply it's not
because it wasn't a plea it's after
you've gone to trial and when all of
that is said and done one can still
challenge the ALS as long as they submit
their hearing request within 30 days of
the date of the arrest they can do that
separately or they can do it globally in
conjunction with an agreement with the
prosecution I I hope that answers your
question
out that little tendril you put on the
end that I was under the impression that
if you had to negot
you pled guilty had to deal with the
prosecution the ALS was a separate issue
and part of the negotiation of the
accepting the guilty pleate would be
that the prosecution would move to get
rid of the ALS now you say the Little
Hook was that even if you go to trial
and are found guilty they can still that
part that was that's a new element you
brought in even if they're found guilty
not a plea that they could still after
within 30 days or whatever you said
could still go to the DMV to try to get
the
ALS uh lifted without the cooperation of
the prosecution is that true it
is because the regulation
uses specifically the word plea and so
it limits the ability to withdraw the
ALS to a circumstance where there's been
trial thank you no further questions
sir the chair calls Lieutenant Chris
Casco
not
me morning chairman honorable committee
members uh for the record my name is
Eddie Edwards assistant commissioner at
Department of Safety to my right is
Lieutenant Chris storm who is the
commander of our special services unit
for the State Police to my left is
attorney Chris Casco who is the chief of
our prosecutors and hearings
Bureau I just wanted the uh committee to
note that this legislation is a part of
the Department's safey priority
legislation this year because of some of
the things that uh we're going to
discuss this this morning one of those
things that was uh alarming and quite
concerning to the department was uh drug
cases these are cases involving alcohol
and marijuana fentanyl or cocaine other
um drugs one or more
drugs I'm sorry two or more drugs in
poly drug cases and
in9 New Hampshire there were 3% we that
was 3% of our uh cases in 2021 that
represented 40% of our cases involving
more than just alcohol and so so this
legislation is part of a broader public
policy to make sure that New Hampshire
roads
are are safe for travel uh we've had a
number of uh deaths on our on our
roadways and uh we get an enormous
amount of interactions with families who
lost loved ones asking what New
Hampshire is doing and as you can
imagine I'm sure you've traveled on 101
95 93 and you saw you've seen people
flying past you you've seen the the
crashes and so uh this is also impacting
wrongway drivers which is another big
problem in our state uh as you can
imagine that's a 3,000 4,000 pound
weapon driving in the opposite direction
the headon traffic and uh that's
becoming an increasing uh problem for us
uh one of the primary reasons not the
sole reason but one of the primary
reasons for wrongway drivers is
impairment so with that I I'll have uh
attorney Casco open some more open
comments and I'll turn over to
Lieutenant storm good morning Mr chair
committee members for the record I'm
Chris Casco I'm an attorney for the
Department of Safety the rationale
behind this bill is to reduce the rate
of refusal for people who are arrested
for DUI in New Hampshire because it has
been a longstanding problem and looking
at the data one way to address that and
to encourage people to take a chemical
test is by changing the penalty for
refusal so that's what this Bill does
and I cite in my position paper some of
the data that shows New Hampshire
historically has had a high rate of
refusal as Senator Ganon told you at the
beginning almost seven out of 10 people
refuse to take a test and that's not
good for Public Safety and frankly it's
not always good for the individual
because what happens for a
refusal that suspension time runs
consecutively to any time of suspension
in court so encouraging people to take a
test will be helpful and that's what
this bill is attempting to do because it
will not change the law in New Hampshire
for those who take the test so for those
who take the test the suspension for a
test over the legal limit will stay the
same 180 days in 2 years because what
the data has suggested that state that
have a more significant penalty for
refusing like Vermont our neighbors to
the north they have much higher
suspension periods after First Defense
they have a
lifetime suspension and also a liftime
suspension with no right to get your
license back ever if you have subsequent
refusals so the data would suggest that
making a more significant license
suspension pen penalty will encourage
people to take a chemical test after
they are charged with
DUI another thing that this does that I
don't think anyone has touched upon in
terms of making something a second
offense this will add those who have a
refusal in another state will be a
predicate offense to make a longer
suspension period applicable whereas
under current law it needs to be a New
Hampshire refusal or a New Hampshire
prior DUI conviction so that's another
pretty important factor of this bill is
to
allow a an out of state offense an out
of state refusal to constitute a
predicate offense which would make an
arrest here in New Hampshire a second
offense to which the longer suspension
periods will
apply another way that this bill
encourages people to take take the
test is with the the current
administrative rule that attorney Moses
did do a good job of explaining was the
withdrawal of the ALS that can happen
under the administrative rules of the
Department of Safety this would limit
the withdrawal rule it wouldn't change
it for people who take the test if they
plead guilty to the DUI and they've
taken the test the state as part of a NE
negotiated plea will have the legal
Authority still they have the legal
Authority now to withdraw that entire
administrative license suspension as
opposed to under this bill the only time
you can reduce is 180 days in exchange
for a plea in court so you always will
serve at least 180 days if you refuse
even if you plead guilty to DUI a
subsequent offense could be reduced from
three years to two .5 years so that will
make a significant difference because
those who take the test and have tested
over could still have that withdrawn by
by entering a plea and it's important
for those entering a plea they accept
responsibility there'll be
Rehabilitation and the mandatory Alcohol
counseling program
will act to rehabilitate people so the
more people we can get into counseling
to to address an underlying alcohol
problem the better so those who take the
test they go to court they can have a a
lesser license suspension they're
they'll be more likely to get into the
treatment and less likely to come before
the court again and be arrested for DUI
and then another piece of this that is
an incentive for those to take the test
is that for those who test High High to
the point of being an aggravated DWI a
0.16 or greater for someone who's 21 or
older right now someone convicted of
aggravated based on a high test has a
mandatory jail sentence whereas this
bill will allow a judge to suspend that
entire sentence to just give further
encouragement for people to take the
test in New Hampshire I'm happy to take
any
questions and Lieutenant storm I think
can add definitely from the law
enforcement perspective as
well abut thank you very much uh my name
is Lieutenant Chris storm I am the
special services Commander for the
Department of Safety Division of State
Police I uh I run the state police's um
impaired driving program um and also
serve on the New Hampshire impaired
driving um task force um the New
Hampshire driver uh impaired driving
task for has identified this refusal
problem as our number one priority to um
fix um we are one of the worst states in
the entire country when it comes to
refusal um we need to fix that problem
right now the penalties are the exact
same for whether you take the test or
you don't take the test as far as the
statute so we need to stop that from
happening so that we can keep these
roadways safe we can stop these crashes
from happening and we can stop the
recidivism of people just continuing to
drive um impaired here in our state and
with our neighbors right now and the
potential of that um marijuana
legislation passing um all of our
neighbors have recreational marijuana
and we're seeing a higher increase of
people that are utiliz the utilization
of marijuana on our roadways so we're
trying to stop that refusal rates from
happening so that we can actually um
keep our roadway safe by not having
these people out here driving impaired
um Chris hit all those points very very
well so I'd be both of us be more than
willing to answer any questions that you
have thank you yeah we have a few um I
think though you just hit a really
interesting point for me so right right
now if if you pull someone over and
they're let's assume they're
0.09 okay they refuse to take the test
their license suspension is how much
it's a on the ALS side of the house it'
be 180 days and if they take the test
and they come up 0.009 what is the
license suspension 180 days so right now
there's no incentive to take the test I
might as well roll the dice and go to
trial is that pretty much much what I'm
you are correct representative okay and
if I may jump in really the the one
distinction is how the license
suspension if both are imposed after the
cas is is
finished the the refusal suspension time
would run consecutively or after the
court suspension but you kind of have to
look at both but the term is the exact
same for both the refusal
and susp if you were convicted did um
after refusing the test you could look
at 360 days of suspension is that what
I'm hearing yes you could 180 plus 180
they'd be on and after and you'd think
that would be an incentive but I think
it's just it's legal terminology to some
extent legal ease for lack of a better
term and the consecutive versus
concurrent is on the back of the form
but I think even lawyers it can be
confusing language so for the average
person to understand that distinction
based on using that terminology I think
it's just not it's it's been shown to
not be sufficient to encourage people to
take the test and we think that
increasing the terms will be a much
better way to encourage
testing with regard to the um expansion
to to the out of state what is your look
back period going to
be the look back period essentially in
law there is not a look back period but
the practice has been to use the same
10-year lookback period for the criminal
offense for DUI second it needs to be
within 10 years of the prior so that has
been the practice and refusal yes that's
in the practice 10 to use a 10-year look
back period okay um representative
scitec thank you Mr chair uh attorney
Casco you used the word predicate
predicate case what's that mean just
meaning a condition to make something a
second offense so to be subject to right
now it's a
2-year suspension for refusing a second
time but right now you would need either
a prior DWI conviction which would be a
predicate offense or a prior refusal in
New Hampshire which would be kind of a
condition a predicate offense would be
the prior condition that would make
something the second offense subject to
the longer suspension term this adds
outof State DUI convictions in outof
state refusals to make someone subject
to the longer suspension period as
whereas right now if you have a prior
DUI conviction and you're arrested in
new h a prior DUI conviction in another
state Massachusetts for example and
you're arrested for DUI in New Hampshire
and you refuse use your time would be
180 days for a first offense because
under current law it does not recognize
an outof State conviction as something
that will make you subject to that
period I have a different question and
this uh Mr chair this may be out of
order and I'll ask it offline of
Lieutenant storm but I I'd like to a
quick primer on what are these different
tests I hear chemical test I what's the
what what are could somebody tell us
what's in the the zoo of tests yeah that
would be actually a good idea because um
assistant commissioner Edwards mentioned
the the the drug issue as being a prime
driver of this however do we have a test
available for the drugs and let's talk
about that yeah absolutely so I can
easily answer that question for your
representative so there's there's
basically three different uh four
different um testing um things that
would happen first and foremost we'd
have our breath test that would come
under um our breath instrument the
second would be blood um obviously a
legal blood draw done and then the third
and the fourth are kind of in
conjunction with together the third is
say that individual doesn't um take
testing out on the side of the road we
read them their LS form they agree to
testing we can give them what they call
physical tests so that's our
standardized field sobriety battery and
then to to your point um about the drug
side of the house if they um if we feel
that they're under the influence of
drugs we can do what they call a drug
recognition evaluation on that
particular individual so those are the
four those are the four cruxs of the
actual testing that we would do on a
particular
individual can you explain the drug
recognition sure it's a u basically it's
a national program that is a 12-step
process that we go through that anybody
that we believe that is on something
other than just alcohol so once that
persons determine that they are not
impaired by alcohol and we believe that
they are impaired by a particular drug
we'll do a 12 12ep process to them that
will be able to show the signs and
symptomology of that they are under the
influence of seven different drug
categories and basically every drug
category that will impair your ability
to drive would fall under one of those
seven drug categories and have the
courts recognized the uh the evidence of
those tests as being admissible and
Reliant yes representative they have
thank you um representative
Stone thank you and thank you for taking
my question my basic question is has
there been a huge increase from the
Department of Safety administering uh
blood draws versus intoxilizer use I
believe we have that data um for you
um I can tell you right now the state of
New Hampshire as a whole not just the
department of safety or the the Troopers
or anybody that works for us the state
of New Hampshire as a whole does about
1750 um blood draws per year so from all
agencies that would do a legal blood
draw we're doing about 7 uh50 as far as
our breath testing
do um yeah I I can't tell you exactly
how many um we're doing we average in
the state roughly around um we've we've
decreased a lot in our DWI due to
Manning and um so forth but um last year
we were somewhere in the 3,000 range for
total DWI that were brought into um
actual ALS forms that came into the um
to the DMP thank you representative
Murray thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question this might be kind of
silly but I'm wondering um why you want
to incentivize taking someone taking the
test if it's um an admission of guilt to
not take the test like if it's like kind
of either way I'm kind of confused like
why so that's a that's a great question
so on the administrative side of the
house the the test or no test actually
kind of doesn't matter but on the
criminal side when you're actually in
front of it the the best evidence is
obviously showing that that impairment
level so to be able to prove that case
and to make it so it's absolutely proper
the best thing to do is to have a test
to show that that particular individual
was under either alcohol Andor drugs and
if I may add to that representative
Murray I think a reason to incentivize
really for the citizens benefit is that
there's a perception out there in
misunderstandings about how much alcohol
equals an 08 and some people will think
gez I had one beer I might be in 08 they
get stopped they get arrested they don't
do well on the field sobriety tests and
if they're always told oh you just
refuse those that person who may be well
under the legal limit is going to refuse
and be in the system so it it gives them
an opportunity to show the officer that
they're actually not impaired and they
won't end up in the system so that
that's another good reason for testing
in New Hampshire into to not have this
misunderstanding of oh you just always
refuse that which I think in New
Hampshire to some degree that's what the
public thinks you just refuse
that representative
PR so I heard testimony about the form
that it doesn't really very
explicitly say what happens if you don't
if you refuse is there a way we can make
that clearer so say this is the option
if you take the test you can be subject
to this if you refuse the test this is
what's coming nice big bold so they get
it and and I also agree with you the
word on the street is just refuse
because it works out better for you
sometimes it does I guess sometimes it
doesn't but that's what a lot of people
believe and I'm not really sure why if
if this uh law is uh passed we will be
changing our form these the forms are
laid out in Rule and that form will be
changed to reflect the new changes and
uh there will be a public hearing at the
department for that and it'll go before
jail car so we'll make sure that those
Muse thank you um the refusal rate which
seems to be drifting somewhere between
70 and 80% seems really really high but
there doesn't seem to be a huge amount
of difference between New Hampshire's
current statute and other states that
have refusal rates that are actually
much
lower one of the things that I'm I'm
really curious about are are there other
factors in addition to the uh uh the
severity of the penalty uh that impact
refusal
rate yeah that that's a good question I
think probably in some of it as we've
just referenced that kind of word on the
street is that you just refuse you'll do
better so I think that's that
contributes to it and I think some of it
may be the idea of hey I don't have to
do that it's my right to refuse which I
know certainly attorney Moses would
argue yes there's an absolute right to
refuse in New Hampshire from my
perspective because the implied consent
law is the way it is I I think that
suggests that there really is no right
to refuse because your license is
suspended it's within 30 days after you
refuse and you can have a hearing but
you'll have to go to court and the two
are unrelated so you may serve a double
license suspension if you contest
everything and you're found liable at
the hearing and found guilty in court so
I think correcting the perception of
there's this right to refuse in making
refuse making taking the test something
that is always not going to work in your
favor which I don't think is necessarily
accurate and and I know attorney Moses
mentioned that a lot of people don't
trust the breath test and I think that's
true to some degree although now in New
Hampshire we have the intoxilizer 9000
machine which is a newer machine for a
long long time we had to have the
intoxilizer
5000 because the law in New Hampshire
from our Supreme Court was that we
needed to still use a machine that
produced a second sample capture tube
that could then be tested so for a long
time we had to use old technology for
the breath test we finally were able to
amend the statute to go to the newer
technology that does not provide a
second sample but someone has the
absolute right to get an independent
sample of their blood at a hospital in
New Hampshire to either corroborate or
not corroborate the breath test so I
think if there's some education about
the process to some degree maybe you get
more people taking the test and you
don't get people getting arrested who
had one beer because they think refusing
is the right thing to
do
follow would it be fair to say that
maybe what we have here uh is maybe more
of a failure to communicate than a
penalize respectfully representative
that that administrative license
suspension form that we have been
talking about is a very detailed form I
know attorney Moses focused on the
aspect that it doesn't tell a CDL holder
what the consequences are and that's
correct in our Supreme Court has had
cases looking at consequences of
refusing or taking the test and I don't
want to get too far into the weeds but
the Supreme Court looks at whether
something is a direct consequence which
is something that needs to be on the ALS
form as opposed to an indirect
consequence that does not an example of
a direct consequence that is one of the
questions on the form is that the person
has to be told that if they refuse that
will be admissible in court because
that's a direct consequence as opposed
to
someone does not need to be told that if
there a one six or more that's an
aggravated DWI subject to a higher
penalty that has been ruled to be an
indirect consequence so far the CDL
consequences have been ruled by our
Superior Courts to be indirect and I
would suggest that a CDL license holder
needs to have a higher knowledge level
of the law and that they should really
know full well that even if they're in
their own car if they refuse they should
know as that part of that higher level
of knowledge that a a special license
holder should have they really should
have a higher degree of knowledge and
should know that if they refuse their
CDL will be suspended for a year because
they're entrusted with driving tractor
trailer trucks out on our roadways and
we need to be sure those people are safe
and they know the law and they have a
special license just like I had a
license to practice law so I should be
held to a higher standard of certain
person could you um touch on where this
let's say this gets passed and the
governor signs it where would that put
us as far as Across the Nation goes um
with regard to this would we be the
highest the middle lowest where will we
be as far as the are you saying as far
as the
penalty
that would be on par with many many many
states already that have that um there
are some that are similar to us there
across the board it's all probably on
that first offense anywhere from I've
seen um as uh low as 90 days all the way
up to the year the ones that have the
lower are the ones that are higher as
far as the refusal rates go okay so to
lower the automatic suspension the
higher the refusal rate the lower the
conviction rates for oui I don't know
about the conviction rate NE
I could get but in Hampshire um without
the tests uh would you in Hampshire with
more people refusing that would assume
that that would lead to lower conviction
rates because you don't have the
evidence is that true or not in some
instan yes it is okay representative
Newell thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I have kind of
a two-parter if you don't mind and um it
speaking about kind of the poly
substance cases is and uh you referenced
that there up you know 2009 it was 3% up
to I think you said 40% in 2021 and I'm
I'm so the first part of my question is
is that based on the uh right around 20%
of the cases that we test that that
people do actually take the test it just
seems like a pretty small sampling if
we're trying to have accurate numbers
those are a um result of test uh testing
done by our Prime lab So based upon all
of
cases that came
in okay so even if somebody refused the
test they would still be tested and that
would be included in this data not not
that they refuse okay we wouldn't know
okay um the other part of my question if
you don't mind me follow okay um the
other part of my question is about um
you know in keeping with the poly
substance um in marijuana being one of
the examples alcohol and marijuana um
but marijuana stays in your system for a
lot longer and so my question is is that
taken into consideration um when we're
when uh defining whether or not that
would actually impair someone's driving
so I can speak a little bit to that so
there's there's a couple different
things so yes marijuana absolutely
metabol marijuana stay in your system
for for quite some time the active
actual agent um Delta 9 tetrah hydr
canaban the actual impairing agreement
actually doesn't stay in your system
very long so we get that hopefully get
that blood tested um quickly hence part
of the need to have a uh no refusal side
of the house so we can actually get that
evidence the carboxy and hydroxy
metabolites do stay in your but those
are not impairing substance it just
basically shows that there was a
presence or that you actually had done
that but the actual impairing ingredient
that Delta 9 tetrahydrogen Abol that's
what we're actually looking for thank
you representative Stone thank you and
thank you for taking my question
currently under ALS how do we handle uh
narcotics only or non-narcotic is that
still a penalty or is it treated
differently under the
alcohol and drugs are treated the exact
same way so if you so if you take the if
you refuse to take the test um the
refusal stuff is the same if you take
the test on a drug related case there is
no
AOS so it actually only applies to the
alcohol currently correct if on the
refusal side of the house it is both
alcohol and drugs if you take the test
it only applies to alcohol follow isn't
that kind of problematic it is but
there's a couple different different
reasons for that um we um we don't want
to change that because if you
representative took a certain kind of
drug and you've been taking it for 30
years and you come back positive for
that particular drug that's not
necessarily a good thing for us to then
suspend your license for something that
you've been taking for 30 years does
that make sense followup wouldn't the uh
State chemist be able to testify about
the levels that are in your body if was
causing impairment during your operation
of a motor vehicle so at no point and
the and
the department of safety is never going
to want to have per limit for any drugs
because there is no scienic data that
shows that having a per se limit for any
particular drug it's it's variable to
dependent on that particular individual
so we could never actually set a level
um representative tenar could take in um
Xanax for the first time in his life and
be extremely impaired um you know
representative Newell could have been
taking it for 30 years and her levels
would be so much higher but she actually
wouldn't be impaired where
representative tzar could be falling
down drunk thank you so it's a
combination of the officer observations
of their operation combined with the
levels that come back from the tests
that give you the full picture of that
operator's uh condition so the refusal
takes away a big part of that so all
that were left is what the officer sees
as far as whether or not someone's
inebriated or intoxicated you're 100%
correct okay thank you that's
particularly true with drugs because the
only only way to do that is with a Dr a
drug recognition
expert um representative N I see you and
represent
Murray representative Newman thank you
Mr chair um I'm just curious I'm
thinking about a first offender type
thing um is there currently available in
the state a limited type license for the
purposes of continued employment or
something like that and if so does this
law affect that there is a ship license
and it does not this would not affect
any part of the hardship license for
that first offender and that's for a New
Hampshire resident
only represent
Murray thank you Mr chair um I just
wanted to ask a clarifying question
because I believe Senator Ganon said
that this is now only about the alcohol
testing but we've been talking about the
drug testing as well so I was just
wanted to understand if it's about if
we're addressing both concerns at this
bill so so the answer to that is we're
addressing the fact of the refusal for
all substances the um and what Senator
Ganon was correct as far as the alcohol
side of the house that doesn't affect it
very much for anything that someone
that's actually participating and taking
a test nothing is going to change as far
as if you take a test and it's alcohol
related nothing will
change in fact in as um attorney Casco
said the one thing that we did um change
is the fact that if someone blows over
that point 6 we don't want to penalize
them for cooperating with the police we
have that opportunity if something is so
egregious that that opportunity will
still be
there but it is not fair to just
penalize someone if you're a030 and you
refuse you get the same thing as someone
that is a 0.8 if you take the test and
you're and you're cooperating with the
police and you come back at a 016 now
we're going to send you to jail we
didn't find that to be and I think
everybody would say that that's not a
fair thing to do we still have that
opportunity if the case is egregious to
that you'd have to end up going because
it's still aggravated DWI but we will
will be able to suspend that jail
sentence for someone that's willing to
cooperate and help um and you know
basically take ownership for what
they've
done so for clarification for the
committee this would stiffen the the
penalty for refusal but at the same time
it gives the opportunity to take away
the minimum mandatory on the aggravated
oui because currently if someone's
aggravated it's an automatic um sentence
to jail
correct and if they take the test and
they're over that the judge can use
discretion and say okay no um that's
100% correct so okay thank you any
further questions representative
Pratt thanks for taking my question um
you were talking about testing do you
use uh like urine testing Vans for
commercial
only New Hampshire is no longer a urine
State at all we do not test urine at our
state laboratory um other than through
the department Corrections for certain
parole um but as far as impairment or
out there we do not use urine anymore
okay
thanks just thank you for your testimony
thank you thank you for your time thank
you is there anyone else wishing to
testify this bill who has not fill out a
pink carard seeing no one else I hereby
Clos public
next
I am opening the public hearing on
Senate Bill 313 and I invite the sponsor
to introduce it or no you're here on
their
behalf thank you good morning chairman
Roy members of the committee I am Grant
bossy here to introduce Senate Bill 313
on behalf of Senator Pearl the Bill's
Prime sponsor this bill is a request
from the Department of Corrections to
update our criminal code to reflect the
realities of the 21st century mamus a
term I didn't know until this bill was
filed is a legal term for the official
documentation accompanying a person
convicted and sentenced to the
Department of Corrections current law
requires the clerk of the court to
deliver a copy to the Department of
Corrections but does not specify that
such delivery can take place
electronically during the pandemic the
courts and correction system greatly
increased their e filing capabilities
and found that this method worked quite
well but the stat and while the statute
does not prohibit electronic delivery of
sentencing documents it doesn't
specifically mention them either s SP
313 would clarify that electronic
delivery is allowed the bill also
requires delivery of mamus to the
arresting municipality and requires doc
to examine the documents to ensure their
authenticity sp sp 313 would clarify RSA
662 8 and N to better reflect current
practice and to ensure that communities
receive notice when people they've
arrested are sentenced to State Prison
if you have any questions I would defer
to the department or make sure Senator
Pearl gets you an answer Senator Pearl
thanks you for your consideration and
support of Senate Bill 313 thank you
Graham
I just say that nimus is a verb of the
send good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Jane Graham I
am the Strategic Communications
administrator for the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections uh the New
Hampshire Department of Corrections uh
asked uh Senator Pearl to bring this
bill forward I don't want to uh get too
much into um Mr bossy's testimony
because it's pretty much the same as the
one that we have prepared this is just a
reflect updating the language to uh
specifically mention that we're allowed
to accept a Minimus electronically so we
are getting that sentencing document
primarily electronically directly from
the court now whereas in the past it
would be hand deled um with that
endorsement from the
sheriff does any I'm happy to take
questions so just for clarity for
everybody all this is doing is bringing
our paper system electronic for handling
Ms is that it is yes any
questions seeing none thank you
representative Jam you turned your head
just I waved I didn't recognize the
haircut
okay thanks uh my my only question is it
says here department is committed to
carefully examining each Minimus
received through electronic channels to
ensure its authenticity can you speak to
how you're doing that is it like a
follow-up phone
call the Minimus is coming directly from
the court system so we're receiving it
directly from directly from the clerk of
the courts so we can see where it's
coming
from thank you thank you see no further
questions thank you thank thank you
anyone else wish to testify on this bill
who hasn't testified seeing no one here
hearing see 11 Bill commissioner
fees that I open the public hearing on
Senate Bill
425 we have any
cards anyone here wishing to testify in
425 anyone on the committee know
anything about Senate Bill
I well I have a conflict I'm not sure
whether I'll participate or not but
shouldn't we wait for 318 to come back
from Finance before we do anything with
this well that would that would assume
we had a public hearing and didn't uh go
to an executive session but yeah are you
going to introduce this one or we 25
okay I have learned lot here this
morning so it's like you're doing a good
committee here um this is relative to
bail Commissioners fees I happen to know
some of them are behind me um a lot of
bail Commissioners and I've watched the
last dozen years or so as they've been
paid the same $40 no gas and there is a
lot of talk that eventually maybe we'll
have a whole different system we'll have
paid Comm you know more educated or
something uh bail Commissioners but at
the moment and we've been doing this
year after year we not giving them any
more money we don't give them mileage uh
the cost of living you can probably tell
me representative $40 12 or 14 years ago
it's probably should be 80 to 100 um my
local bail commissioner um who will be
speaking behind me goes out many
Saturday nights at 2 in the morning
drives to Manchester interviews the
person sees if someone who should you
know it can be a criminal case could be
something he has to decide whether or
not in many circumstances whether or not
they get out or not um and so he has a
huge responsibility um very important to
our community um it's part of the bail
problems probably um that we're all
trying to address and other bills and
he's getting $40 and that's so by the
time he drives to Manchester's home he's
probably spending $10
$15 they don't get paid every time some
um so now you're down to $25 sometimes
for something that's could take him 1 or
two in the morning he gets home at 4:
or5 in the morning he's walking out
there with $25 maybe um so we think
until we address what we really want to
do with um fail Commissioners whether or
not that's going to be a much more uh
educated Force who has criminal you know
degrees and something pertaining to this
but in the meantime while we're dealing
with the system and the people we have
are doing a great job the $40 just isn't
commensurate with the respons
responsibilities and the costs they have
so we in the meantime till we address it
in a more detailed fashion would like to
pay them slightly more again it's
including their gas mileage which they
don't get a separate fee for so 40 would
like to make to 60 still not even near
keeping up with the cost of living but
just recommend recognizing these people
that they're doing a hard job uh we if
we paid these people $100,000 each this
roughly a hundred of them Plus benefits
we're looking 10 to 15 million with
Benefits we're saving it he's going out
and he's collecting on his own on a
credit card so we're saving the state
tens of probably $10 million a year it's
a wonderful system for us financially um
we can get into details whether or not
it's the best system but in the meantime
would like to and he's um the gentleman
behind us will be testifying they're
losing bail Commissioners all the time
the burden is going on an aging group of
people to turn out at 2: in the morning
and it's just it's not sustainable but
in the meantime the some of them are
leaving because of this $40 is all
they're getting would like to retain the
ones we have as long as we want to keep
this system in place that's all I really
have to say thank you Senator and I I'm
pretty sure that every version of the
bill that's flying around all raises
their pay so okay we're we're very
friendly to that idea okay thank you
very much thank
you sorry thought it was clear you're
off
you get
a sir before you leave could you fill
out one of those pink cards so we have
them for our records as to who testified
you don't have to do it right now just
yeah before you I didn't know that's
okay my name is Eddie menis I'm from
Sandown New Hampshire um been a bail
commissioner for eight
years and longer as uh each day
progresses it's a fascinating
job um I believe you're ba commissioner
Mr St so it's a learning curve when you
first get appointed I'm very
knowledgeable in the law I make it my my
duty to know what's going on and how to
implement what I have to
do I know we're only here for the the
money aspect of it and it is low there's
no question about
it everything that the Senate has said
is
true but in our family growing up when
you take a a job you do the job to the
best of your ability that's how we were
raised I know some of my fellow bail
Commissioners that aren't doing it
anymore it was the money issue that
dissuaded them from
continuing and they were extremely
knowledgeable and people that I bird dog
with to learn the
process Course once I did learn the
process they changed the paperwork a
year
later but you just keep learning and
helping other bail Commissioners when
they call you the ones with the
extensive knowledge get the phone calls
from people who are just coming on board
to actually what to do in certain
instances and that's a real nice thing
when you have a network of people that
help each other I hope you all
appreciate what we do we do it to help
the police the state police the
Sheriff's Department and we're basically
on call 24 hours a day seven days a
week and I hope that they raise the fee
to at least
$60 as an incentive to maybe other
people coming on board if you have any
questions I'd be happy
them represent
Murray thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I was just
wondering we've heard a lot from bail
Commission in this committee um not only
about you know the fee being too low but
also an inability to collect that fee um
and I'm just wondering if that's been
your
experience the I do very well on
collecting the
10% do I like that
no some people just don't have
it it's not going to
happen and you go into this knowing that
all
right obviously sometimes people um pass
away too because they were on uh
different
items I just want one other thing I'd
like to say I'm glad I was here for the
earlier one it was really informative
for
me I thank you for that you're very
welcome uh representative Jam thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question I I want to note that uh after
youve build two people under this if
this bill passed you actually make more
than we do but that that nor
withstanding I the last part of this the
last sentence is if if defendant is IND
Indigent the fee is
waved that's current law uh can you
explain how you determine if if a uh
defendant is indigent so that you can
wave that for them the judge when they
go to court the judge determines that
gather thank you and my understanding is
when you make contact with them at the
police station to to state their bail
what the bail conditions will be um that
is when you take that fee correct
correct if they have it thank
you see no further questions thank you
this morning for coming in thank you
ladies and gentlemen is there anyone
else wishing to testify on this bill who
wasn't testified see none everybody
closes public
hearing next one
11:30
actually
e
that I'm opening the public hearing on
Senate Bill
460 and I recognize Senator Carson
okay I got to start over again because I
didn't press the red
button good morning Mr chairman
and there we go okay good morning Mr
chairman and good morning uh members of
the House criminal justice committee for
the record my name is Sharon Carson and
I have the pleasure of representing
Senate District 14 comprising the towns
of London Dair Hudson and Auburn and I
have for your consideration sener Bill
460 um Mr chairman this bill was brought
to me by the department of safety and um
I wanted just to uh highlight a few
things we have seen an increasing threat
to Public Safety due to the rapid
Evolution and accessibility of small
uncraft uh unmanned aircraft systems
current New Hampshire law Lacks adequate
prohibition and penalties to address
both negligent and nefarious use of
these
devices um we did have an incident on
August 23rd
2023 where a medical H helicopter was
grounded for 10 minutes due to a small
drone flying in the de uh vicinity
causing a delay in critical patient
care we really need to have uh
legislation in ensuring the safety of
New Hampshire citizens and protecting
critical infrastructure from potential
threats caused by these small drones um
Mr chairman um at this point I would
like to conclude my testimony because I
know many of you have dealt with the
issue of drones for those of you who've
been here for a while but um the Senate
amended the bill and it's there seems to
be an issue with the amendment of the
bill um we there was a request that we
take out a certain portion of it and we
did we've subsequently found out that it
was critical to the bill and so I just
wanted to alert all of you to the fact
that it probably should go back in the
bill um and the this committee and you
Mr chairman in your wisdom will figure
out how to do that so um we do have
people here from the Department of
Safety that are can uh discuss the need
for this bill and so I would thank you
all for your time and your consideration
this this morning thank you if you could
just leave us with that piece that you
took out we'd be happy to put it back
for you they they have that thank
Muse the the amendment that you refer of
could you're referring to could you just
just tell us really quickly what uh I'm
sorry the the original bill that you
would like to put back in can you just
summarize really quickly what that
involves well the Senate we passed a
amendment number 02 0821 s um and it
took out the
section um and I believe it it was
pointed out to me um exactly where it is
I'm not sure but we had received a
request to take that out and so we took
it out they'll be able to show you
exactly where it is and I did have one
one quick
followup as the prime sponsor I know
you're you're aware of the fact that um
there have been several incidents uh
with drones dropping things uh on people
the bill seems to be limited to things
like dangerous projectiles bombs and
things of that nature in also in in 2023
there was an incident in Manchester
where feces and garbage and other things
were dropped on homeless people would
you have any objection to uh widening
the scope of the bill to include things
of that nature thank thank you for the
question um representative we didn't get
testimony to uh incidents of happening
of things like that I think we can all
agree that that's really reprehensible
behavior and if the committee in working
with the Department of Safety feels that
it needs to be included I don't as the
prime sponsor of the bill I wouldn't
have any issue with
youch I Sen Carson I have a technical
question uh I wanted to look at this
bill online last night and I saw two
Senate amendments but I didn't see how
it left the Senate as amended so I don't
know that I have a final version of the
Senate yes I have I have my copy um uh
yeah we're all set we have it don't
worry about it okay all right I just
want to make he's just if you needed
something to make sure you had it
okay thank you Senator we're good thank
you very
much chair recognizes um David Kev cover
what is
that
morning oh um do you have any Chris
Chris where do you want me to start I
apologize if you want represent we can
go first David could follow up with us
if that would uh if that would help
that'll make things a lot smoother for
much morning I have some handouts for
you
folks
sorry for all this confusion we uh we
also couldn't find the amendment we read
the amendment this morning and realized
it was uh there was stuff that was taken
out so again I'm Lieutenant Chris storm
I'm from the uh Special Services of the
State Police part of the special
services again we're going to switch
hats from the first bill I am also in
charge of the um uh uas group and the
counter uas um division of the State
Police um um to my left is um ader selli
um from the New Hampshire Fusion Center
to talk um a little bit about some of
the threats that we are seeing with um
the uas and why this bill is so
important to be able to pass um and
you're going to hear afterwards from our
uh friends at dot um Aeronautics uh in
reference to um the problem uh with the
small unmanned aerial systems also known
as uas or drones one of the biggest
things that um we we're having right now
is that we have no way to enforce any
things that are happening um to
representative Muse's um point that um
situation that happened in Manchester um
we're absolutely aware of that that's AB
absolutely reprehensible and we need
something to be able to go out and
actually enforce those um those federal
laws right now part 107 which you'll see
is part of those handouts you'll see a
lot of stuff about the U Federal um
rules and regulations right now they're
barely being enforced by anybody through
the federal um Aviation Administration
what we're asking is basically to adopt
those federal regulations and make them
into a state law so that we have that
ability to go out and actually um
enforce those laws unfortunately with
the new amendment that just came with
that bill those were stripped out and
that first part was stripped out so we
need that to be put back in there so
that we can actually go out and do it um
a little context to how this bill came
across we have a um a uas threat working
group that we have people from not only
the department of safety the New
Hampshire Fusion Center Department of
Aeronautics private sector folks people
from the utilities people from the
United States military um other Federal
entities that we've all gotten together
to say what can we do about this problem
that is a very large problem here in New
Hampshire and that we don't want
anything to happen everybody can see all
the stuff that's happening worldwide
with drones and we don't want that
happening here but we also need a way to
um help stop that and help educate the
public into making this um a not okay
thing what we don't want to do is stop
people from using drones they are good
use there there's lots of good uses for
them we are not trying to stop the use
of drones at all I just got one for
Christmas so I'm going to kill this dead
if you're going to take that absolutely
not and and in fact as far as the public
safety goes they are becoming something
that we are utilizing almost on a daily
basis um as far as Public Safety um the
fire service all sorts of different um
entities that are using them for actual
good unfortunately there are people that
are using them for not good it's the
same as a car right like we need a car
to get everywhere we need a car to do
all sorts of things but you can do a lot
of bad things with a car so we're trying
to solve that problem here in New
Hampshire by letting the and having some
kind of legislation so that we can stop
this from happening so the biggest thing
to this legislation is to allow us to
enforce those Federal rules under part
107 which are all within our original
Amendment so hopefully this group is
willing to um
uh go into that subcommittee or wherever
we need to go to add that language back
into the original format of that bill
and uh Mr kovar will be able to talk
somewhat about um where some of that
stuff may have come out afterwards on on
his private sector um side of the house
and I'll let Adam kind of go into what
um just so that you guys kind of get a
basic brief of what we're dealing with
in New Hampshire as far as some of these
um drone problems so that you actually
know when we can make a good um decision
as a group thank you appreciate the time
again again Adam Chelli I've served as a
critical infrastructure analyst for the
past three and a half years at the New
Hampshire information analysis Center um
one quick note on on the section that
was was removed
sorry uh just to highlight kind of the
importance of of that section that was
removed so FAA back in 2021 did a study
uh in a sampling period where they
detected almost 500,000 suas flights uh
from a population of
116,000 uh different platforms so some
of the activity that was identified in
that study falls into that first
category uh that has been removed and we
think is really important uh that that
stays in the bill a couple examples uh
so beyond uh visual line of sight that's
a dangerous operation it's a negligent
use uh if you don't you're not able to
see where that uh vehicle's going uh
that's unsafe 133% of that 470,000 uh
was beyond visual line of sight 21% was
above 400 ft so again you can get into
the those dangerous air corridors and 25
so a quarter of those flights were
conducted at nighttime so those are in
the category of the restrictions U from
that first section that we really think
are important to have in there um in
general uh from threat intelligence
perspective we're in all crimes all
hazards Center at the New Hampshire
information analysis Center so we look
at Global Trends Regional Trends uh to
see what might be coming and one of the
things that's really stood out to us um
and that's kind of captured in in some
of those uh slides that I believe
everyone should have is that information
sharing tactics techniques and
procedures for Bad actors to use
commercially available systems and
modify them uh that information sharing
is is taking place every day on the
internet even just the surface internet
via message boards um particularly as a
result of the Russia uh Ukraine conflict
uh that's really kind of showcasing how
these commercial systems could be used
to execute a Connecticut attack or to do
uh pre-operational surveillance ahead of
an attack so we feel like these are
really important categories and um
really appreciate your your leadership
and support of this effort happy to
answer any questions you might
have represent Jam thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my
question as somebody that uses these for
lawful purposes in my town uh for the
police fire Emergency Management
planning department that sort of thing
one of the things that we that I saw in
your slides was weaponization of the
drones and if this amendment that we
were talking about was to put back in
here uh under the section 107 if you
were to detect a a drone that was
operating in for a nefarious purpose
what would your be be your course of
action so the first course of action and
that's that's part of the biggest part
of getting this enacted right we would
we would contact the local police or us
or anybody that has the whatever law
enforcement has jurisdiction they would
have to go there and immediately deal
with that um if we have a nefarious or a
weaponized drone um our um procedure is
that we'll hopefully locate the operator
we'll hopefully get that down and then
we're going to contact our bomb bomb
squad to First evaluate that x-ray make
sure that it is safe for um anybody else
to get near it and then we'll obviously
um take that in and then um if it's
weaponized more often than not we'll
probably depending on what kind of
weapon it is there's there's all sorts
of things that would go into that but we
would probably have some of our federal
point as a followup um some of those
Partners would include FBI
ATF and Military depending on what it is
you
Newman I have a question and I think it
has to do with the amendment and it was
hard to figure out what was going on
with the Amendment because you took
something out and so it doesn't show in
the amendment which you took out but I
compare compared it to the original and
then compared it to this and it had to
do with um it was a violation for first
or second offense and it was associated
with the Federal Aviation laws or the US
laws for that is that the part that may
be missing yes representative 100% that
that group came together to come up with
all of the things that would mirror what
we were doing and what we were um what
we would like to have happen thank
you
Pratt thanks for answering the question
I have a question about uh how does
property rights come into play with this
I'm property rights if you're using like
say night vision at night on your own
property how would that play into it if
you is it any different on your own
property as it would be in the public so
yeah absolutely so the the the thing
about that is we're not asking to
regulate any type of airspace so we
can't stop somebody from flying their
drone over someone else's house or or
anything like that um as far as um like
peering into Windows or or anything like
that which I think kind of where you're
going with the question um that would
fall under our other Statute in the
disorderly conduct statute that 6449 um
statute that you you couldn't do that
with any kind of
device thank you with regard to um
representative M's earlier question uh
as far as dropping random stuff on
people wouldn't that fall under the uh
assault and battery um already or no it
could it absolutely could I think
anything obviously on prible contact is
is simple assault so absolutely it could
um this just gives us um a better chance
to investigate the mechanism in which it
was that it was actually being delivered
with so that you you can't do that and
you can't do that to somebody or or do
those um he and representative news was
100% correct those horrific acts of
dropping feces and urine and other
things on individuals yeah oh no I mean
you can take it even further at a at a
at a wildcat SC some I mean a college
event I mean bad things bad things can
happen and that's that's part of the
critical interest and and we're not
going to go through every slide for for
you folks but as as you as you look
through those it makes this makes a lot
of sense okay I can just note very
quickly absolutely um so in the category
interference of occupied aircraft you'll
see an image there um of of an airliner
uh coming in on approach in that example
there so there's a deterrence aspect um
that we think will be very valuable here
so that picture was actually posted by a
hobbyist uh that was a Frontier Airlines
uh on approach to McCarron airport in
Las Vegas had 150 people on board and
they posted it to the internet um so
even a lot of this this negligent use is
is undeterred now to some extent uh and
we feel like um this this would help uh
to get some of that deterrence in
place with regard to the the commercial
aircraft there's a height limit a
ceiling on the unmanned aircraft but as
the as the commercial craft comes in its
ceiling goes down how how's that handle
certainly so there is a five um nautical
mile radius around airports that have um
what they call a Bas I'll give it in so
concrete airport per se it's a what they
call a lance airport so um right here
over the state house no one can actually
fly their drone it's zero feet um
because there's an airport within five
nautical miles for that exact reason
depending on which Runway they're coming
in at conquered airport we could
absolutely interfere them by flying them
so there's waivers and so um things that
people under that part 107 um law that
they can do they can get waivers we can
um uh work with uh we we fly um the
state police uses our drone here all the
time to help out with um different
things that are happening here at the
state house all the time um but we have
Direct Communications with the Federal
Aviation and with conquered Airport to
make sure that it's a legal safe thing
to do and the same thing goes for over
at Manchester um Portsmouth uh Lebanon
um we've flown our drones um doing the
right way businessman um dot does it all
the time flying in the proper we need to
negate all those improper uses around
our
airports I guess what I'm asking is for
example where I live is next to Bear
Brook State Park and it seems to be a a
corridor heading into Manchester because
I I see them getting lower and lower so
how do I know what the CE is above it
does it everywhere else it was 400t but
is it here less so it's 400t over the
highest object so that's a little bit
hard to then I got to go to the highest
pine tree I see and go 400 feet above
that you can only go 4 but if you're
over here about 100 yards it's only 400
feet above that so it's a it's a little
bit confusing but it's 400 feet above
that particular thing at no point um
over be Brook State Park as any approach
into Manchester going to be under 400 ft
they're big planes they look pretty
close they look really close um
represent Newman do you have a question
just a comment for the committee the the
way the AFA sets it up and I used to
work for them is it's a wedding cake
upside down wedding cake that goes out
and so like he said five miles around
you can't do anything and then it might
go up to like a th000 feet or 2,000 feet
and then from there on out right up to
and at no point will a drone without a
waiver be allowed to fly over 400 feet
so you have to do a lot of leg work to
get any kind of waiver that allows you
to go over that 400t or Beyond visual
line of sight or anything that is um a
side from that part 107 gotcha thank you
represent
no thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um so it's uh kind of
a two-parter but um my first question is
about um enforceability and kind of
like um is it especially when we talk
about what are the guidelines right uh a
certain height uh being within sight and
things like that so if someone is not um
within sight uh is there a way is there
like GPS on it or some way to track I'm
just curious and yeah absolutely so
there's there's numerous um different um
there's certain detection devices that
are out there that are on the market
that um that you can utilize to
determine where the operator is how high
the um High the um actual uas is um
there's certain things that you can just
tell that there's an impossibility that
someone's able to actually see that
drone from x amount of feet by the size
of the side there's a lot of different
ways that you can go and and do that um
the biggest thing is to be able to
locate that operator speak with the
operator and this isn't something that
we're trying to go out there and just
you know everybody gets a ticket or
everybody gets arrested we need
something that we can also help educate
and our friends at dot are going to we
we'll explain that we're going to work
on an education piece before it's just
something that we're going to go out and
arrest or ticket somebody for um we need
to have that education campaign we need
to have that out there but we need this
if there are those egregious um those uh
egregious situations we're not
necessarily going to go out and you know
the 14-year-old kid that's you know got
his drone for Christmas and he flies and
we're going to go in a you know put him
in handcuffs and put him in the back of
a police car that is not the goal of
this thank you you answered my second
question
anyway these drones now you can actually
fly it and see it on your phone but you
you might not see the so if you lose
sight of the vehicle with your eyes
regardless of you see it on your phone
you you're in violation is that you are
you are there are there are there are
and that's why we're asking for that um
that that basically that Global ability
to do part 107 because as that Tech
technology changes the federal
government's going to change those those
restrictions so we want to make sure New
Hampshire is right so that as those
Technologies um increase or get better
that we're able to follow that along so
if we follow that we'll be in great
shape so the language that you were
looking for would be fluid in other
words it's going to empower you to as
they progress not just as they are
Frozen in Time 100% and that's exactly
what we want to be able to do because
it's not right to anybody if we don't
change with times and for
clarification everything that's illegal
under those cfrs now whether or not you
can enforce them are still illegal just
because in other words the federal
government could come in and enforce
them you're a force multiplier by
allowing you to do it as well is that
correct 100% an analogy that I would use
would be um actually to back to the
first hearing what uh attorney Moses was
talking about when it comes to CDL or F
Federal Motor Carrier it's the same
thing we adopted those 49 cfrs to be
able to go out there and enforce those
commercial vehicle statutes we that in
New Hampshire and all that fine money
and so forth comes to New Hampshire
instead of going to the federal
government because we the state police
or whatever um they enforce that and
Hampshire see no further questions I
don't think good thank you thank
Co than than you
sir so the part of the issue with the
reason sorry we don't know this for fact
but uh it is our opinion and our belief
that could you introduce yourself oh I
apologize that's s right my name is
David kovar uh private sector resident
of EX New Hampshire um I run a small
high-tech company called uro um and the
report that um Adam mentioned where the
fa had the report with all statistics um
I actually built the platform that the
FAA used for Gathering the data and
Performing that analysis so that was
under an FAA contract so we've worked
with the FAA on a professional basis in
terms of trying to gather data to help
educate legislators public and things
like that on what is and is not going on
in the airspace part of the problem that
we've seen um and I think we've observed
it here in New Hampshire as well is that
what humans perceive at drone is or is
not doing may not be what the Drone is
or is not doing and so that's part of
the work that my company has been
performing um I am a private sector um U
member of the working group that Adam
mentioned so that's the counter uas
working group counter uas uh it's it
technically means counter drone but it's
very important I think for all of us to
remember that when we want to counter a
drone what we're really talking about is
finding ways to prevent that drone from
doing something something that is not
supposed to be doing unfortunately in
the military context and what we see in
going on in Ukraine counter drone means
shooting it down but what Chris was
talking about Lieutenant storm was
talking about is that really what we
want to do is go educate the public if
we can educate the public so that they
don't launch that drone in the first
place we've countered that drone and
that's the optimum thing um failing to
do that if we if they launch a drone and
we are able to identify where where the
operator is and to go have a
conversation with that operator and have
that operator land the the Drone and say
okay I understand I was not doing
something appropriate I'll never do this
again we've again countered the Drone
without charging them with anything
without shooting anything down without
any sort of adversarial relationship and
really that's ultimately what the
community is most interested in in terms
of what we call counter uas so that was
a long-winded way of saying I've been
part of that ation in the state of New
now and did you have anything else you
wanted to add about the absolutely so
there's a Association uh the association
of enrud Vehicle Systems International
is uh known as a auvsi uh they are an
advocacy group that's been around for a
number of years now um they and I don't
have the date in front of me I apologize
sent a letter uh which
out to their entire membership saying
that they had filed opposition
testimony uh with respect to this
legislation and that I found out about
that on Sunday I called Lieutenant storm
we both talked about it I then called
auvsi membership U sorry Representatives
during that Monday through Wednesday to
figure out what exactly was going on and
I explained to them what I think has
been explained to all of you we've put a
lot of time and effort into terms of
craft in this legislation we have talked
to the FAA we've talked to FBI we've
talked to Bureau the New Hampshire
Department of Transportation there are a
lot of people that we've worked very
carefully with to ensure that the
proposed legislation will stand the test
of time and the test of the FAA and
things like that there's a long history
of towns and states and other entities
trying to pass laws about drone activity
that essentially stepped on the faa's
toes and the way that usually happens is
if you say we are going to charge
somebody with flying a drone over a
particular place that's the FAA sole
purview they don't no one else has the
ability to say where you can or cannot
operate in the skies above us so if you
start stepping on their toes in that
manner then you start getting into an
area of preemption so this law this this
legislation was particularly crafted to
not do that what the auvsi letter said
is that we were potentially going to
step on areas of FAA preemption and so
let me emphasize two things one is we
were very very careful not to any way
shape or form get on uh to potentially
raise the faa's attention in terms of
preemption the other one is that they
didn't say here are examples of how that
will happen it was this very vague
possibility um and there's a lot of sort
of supposition and backstory about why
they did that um but the sort of
ultimate answer or ultimate outcome of
all that is they went very very silent
and so they have not follow up on that
they're not here to testify about that
opinion and ultimately the FAA has not
either representative Jam thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um in one of the towns adjacent
to mine we have a model aircraft Club
they don't fly drones but they fly model
aircraft um and line of sight all the
time um and some of them are amate radio
operators that use them to go long
distances this would also apply to those
people as well so I will defer to Bureau
Aeronautics for the exact specifics but
the answer is essentially to my
knowledge no so I'm actually I FL I have
flown uh fixed Wing model aircraft uh
well before drones existed I'm a hammer
radio operator um and so one of the
things I will say about that Community
is that they tend to be very compliant
they understand exactly the the sort of
boundaries within with within which they
operate and they are exactly the sort of
community that we want to support we
want to do everything in our possible to
support those hobbyists and those
commercial activities and part of the
effort and this is a national effort but
specifically as represented in this
proposed legis ation is that if we can
help get what we call the clueless
careless and criminal out of the air if
we can start reducing the number of
those sorts of incidents then there will
be less sort of public push back on
drones in general and so if we can get
this legislation through and we can
start um having conversations with
people and if necessary charging them
for this inappropriate or criminal
activity then other people see that the
state of New Hampshire is supporting the
people such as you're talking about
while trying to ensure that the people
are not operating safely are dealt with
appropriately and so that way the public
perception is that the people who are
flying are flying for hobby purposes or
good commercial purposes and that the
people that are flying inappropriately
or criminally are being dealt with
appropriately within the proper bounds
represent
saitech what's the definition of a drone
versus a fixed Wing model plane don't
they wouldn't the fixed Wing model I'm
leading to this wouldn't the fixed Wing
model plane fall under the definition of
a drone yes um so it gets a little bit
nuanced in here but uh essentially all
of those model aircraft that I fly and
the people are flying now are
essentially drones so they're drones is
a shorthand for unmanned aerial vehicle
or actually technically un cruded AAL
vehicle now and so those model fix wings
uh helicopters and what we call now mod
uh multi-rotors or quads all fall under
the same uh
definition to dig in a little bit more
those model airplane clubs are um are
also specifically covered under the FAA
rules and regulations in terms of what
can or cannot be flown when and where
let me just emphasize again that we are
not proposing to enforce the FAA
regulations about what can or cannot fly
in the airspace we are that is strictly
FAA see no further questions thank you
much the chair calls Trisha Lambert and
Jason
levit
good morning chairman and members of the
committee my name is Trisha Lambert and
I am the administrator for the New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
Bureau of
Aeronautics let you introduce and then
I'll go after you good afternoon my name
is Jason levit I'm the uas planner for
Aeronautics so I thought I'd just give a
little bit of background on who we are
and our role um for those that don't
know we're we are the um under RSA 422
we are the regulatory Agency for all
things aviation in the state um one of
the U main things we do is we are the
liaison to the Federal Aviation
Administration
um we also are a promote we also um are
by Statute supposed to promote all
things Aviation so I think that our role
here as we're talking about
um um trying to make penalties for FL
people who do bad things with with uas
or drones
um I just wanted to be really
transparent is that our one of our jobs
is to make is to make Aviation
accessible to everybody um and do that
for the State of New Hampshire working
with the FAA so I our role as part of
the committee that was mentioned several
times was um just that I have been here
for probably the last eight years or so
for many different uas bills and most of
them were here for preemption issues we
pretty much every time it was either the
wrong definition um we we spent a lot of
time trying to get things straight as it
would relate back to the FAA um so
instead of waiting for another bill to
come forward we decided to get together
and to try to put something forward that
would help um the the law enforcement
agencies of the state um while still
trying to promote and educate people
that to fly safely their drone in the
state um so
where we're at with it is that as it
sits right now we are unable to support
this legislation as written um we are
very much um in support of going back to
look at the additional the language that
was put forward um to us a committee um
a subcommittee if that's the will of
this committee to put together to work
thought I guess I'll I'll leave it there
because a lot of things were already
said and I don't I don't want to um I
just I just wanted to be really clear
that we we are here to promote Aviation
and drones are very much that and um we
certainly use it within the department
for a lot of great things um in in
analyzing our infrastructure and um you
know just having that that view traffic
those types of things so I guess did you
want to add anything I guess we'll take
questions if you have them well I guess
my first question would be what is it
bill so well as written there was one
piece when we were at the Senate um that
thank you this is a really good question
um it does not cross over into
422 um I had requested that um because
it's in the criminal statute currently
um their Aviation folks don't know where
to look in the criminal code they're
going to look to 422 and it currently
does not have that so that's that's our
reason why um plus I I feel like the
spirit of the bill when put forward was
not what we were willing to accept
except it paralleled the FAA which it
now further questions representative um
harri gather thank you Mr thank you Mr
chair so are the piece that's missing
that they talked about earlier is that
the piece that you're referring to
there's actually two pieces um the first
piece is
um in the original Bill correct correct
the first piece was was um originally um
relating to the violation of the first
offense and the misdemeanor for a second
and subsequent offense um if such person
operates a small unmanned aircraft uas
in violation of the laws and regulations
of the Federal Aviation
Administration um or other agencies
other agency that governs
Aeronautics and the second piece you do
not have in front of you is um where you
would there would be a section put into
the RSA
422 that crosses back over to to show
them where the
penalties um and violations would be in
statute representative
new thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I'm curious I know you said that you
are um the regulatory area um the
regulatory um whatever you want to call
it anyway but aa's on for the FAA and so
I just want to be very clear are you
speaking on behalf is this is this the
position of the FAA or is this no it is
not it is the position of the New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
Bureau of Aeronautics okay thank you
you're
welcome representative
Newman so I just want to understand
about your objection and is the bill as
introduced which would have those two
things in it what was your position on
the bill is introduced it was in
support okay thank
you if I can add um we asked for an
amendment for the second piece which
would cross back over into the
422 thank you represent Jam thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um the crossover to RSA for
22 um the question is this um this is a
new section what I'm seeing before me as
amended by the Senate and it talks about
uas but it doesn't have a definition so
a lot of times when we have a new
section of law we have definitions that
are used in that section would be
defined are they defined in
422 yes sir they are um thank you for
that question um
we actually made we entered the
definition of the uas to parallel the
Federal Aviation Administration um
several sessions ago um that so that way
new bills that would come up like this
definitions okay thank you no further
questions um I'm going what I'm going to
do is I'm going to appoint a um what I'm
going to call a mini subcommittee and
it's going to consist of Representative
Newman representative Jamber
representative nle um represent Newman
you're the chair if you could just get
find out exactly what we need to put
back in this bill so that it has the
support of everybody and um bring it
back to us um and if you as soon as you
could I don't think we really need to do
study
yeah anyone else wishing to testify on
this pill wasn't
testified seeing none I'm here by
closing the public hearing and if you
could talk to them before they leave
just to see exactly what we need I'd
appreciate
it
right
sorry ant on me it was cuz it was an ant
on him and he but he earlier there was
one and ipped it away then it came back
he had a black
one oh Jee please don't tell me that I'm
gonna flip out it's gross what did you
do with it did you kill ited it it yeah
what is
up
criminal uh justice committee uh for the
record again my name is Sharon Carson
and I represent Senate District 14
comprising the towns of londonairy
Hudson and Auburn and I have for your
consideration this morning Senate Bill
464 to prohibit the uh non-consensual
dissemination of synthetic s uh sexual
images um this legislation broadens the
scope of RSA 644 col 9A New Hampshire
statute that addresses the
non-consensual dissemination of private
sexual images that would be our revenge
porn statute um through this bill the
dissemination of synthetic images images
that have been digitally created and
altered to falsely depict the sexual
conduct of targeting victims will become
a crime in our state this bill could not
come at a more urgent time when
advancements and Technology are
developing at a rapid Pace it's alarming
to know that everyday people are having
their images inappropriate rely used to
create false representations are also
known as deep fakes of themselves
conducting demeaning sexual
acts deep fakes using artificial
intelligence to take a victim's face and
Transplant it onto a sexually explicit
video or image this is made all the more
easier with the creation of new apps and
websites as technological advancement
allow for more for new ways to exploit
people and make these horrific images
millions of New U new deep fake uh
exists online and are nearly always
posted without the victim's
consent these synthetic images are used
to harass intimidate threaten or even
coers a victim and can have astounding
social economic or even legal
consequences on individuals who have
been targeted deep fakes like other
forms of sexual violence and
exploitation have long-term and
devastating impacts on victims this can
include mental health safety economic
loss due to this uh undue violation of
privacy Senate Bill 464 is consistent
with our other efforts our state has
taken to protect victims against
exploitation and sexual violence this is
the right time to pass this legislation
and protect people from being victimized
in such a disgusting way I hope you
would consider passing this important
and timely legislation thank you very
much Mr
chairman um I don't see any questions I
seem to be having deja vu didn't we just
do this I feel like we did okay yeah all
right we actually passed uh HB
139 with the same name and identical
language oh wow I knew I I thought I was
having a senior moment I'm like I know
I've seen this Mr chairman we had a
bipartisan meeting of the I think you
must have indeed thank you um no
questions thank you Senator thank you
very much Mr
Kinsman
good afternoon my name is Eric Kinsman
I'm a lieutenant with the Portsmouth
Police Department and the current
commander of the Hampshire internet
crimes against children task force
current language in RSA 644 col 9-a
restricts iak investigators from
effectively investigating and
Prosecuting an individual who violates
the statute because of how the material
might be disseminated or whether the
material is quote an actual person or
digitally synthetic material today much
of the information in the world to
include photographs movies and other
media has transferred digitally from one
person to another expanding the language
defining how material is disseminated as
written in in s SP 464 will allow law
enforcement to work to protect the
victims when that material is illegally
disseminated electronically or shared on
social media like so often we see now
when it comes to artificial intelligence
AI gener generated models rely on
popular open- Source databases of images
to create what is being described as
hyperrealistic photos these databases
contain billions and billions of images
taken from the internet and mimic visual
patterns to create new photos these
photos literally are virtually
indistinguishable from those which are
genuine while these digital IM while
these digital synthetic images may not
be an actual person they may be
indistinguishable from a p from pictures
of an actual person and therefore create
a situation in which an actual person is
victimized New Hampshire iak supports
s464 and believes it will take an
important step in continuing the
protection of child victims as well
thank you thank you see no questions
thank
Kylie
good afternoon uh Mr chair members of
the committee um my name is Pamela kyg
and I'm the public policy specialist at
the New Hampshire Coalition against
Domestic and Sexual Violence um I'm here
to speak in support of SB 464 I'll keep
it really brief um we also were in
support of HB 1319 which already passed
this body and I just wanted to emphasize
how grateful we are for the sponsors for
bringing forward this proactive uh
legislation that addresses this really
critical issue um this is a specific
form of abuse um that will only increase
if we're not proactive um and take steps
uh to make sure that the appropriate
consequences are in place um and we know
that nearly all deep fake content is
non-consensual and is a form of sexual
exploitation um and so it's also a
really egregious privacy violation which
is something that we as a state um have
worked really hard to address uh
personal privacy issues um and we also
have worked really hard um especially in
recent years um to take every
opportunity to address different forms
of sexual exploitation and abuse so um
on those principles we are just really
grateful to see this move forward uh
Enders
good afternoon Stephen Andrew I'm an
assistant County attorney with the marac
county attorney's office I've been a
prosecutor for over 20 years uh again
maram my county attorney's office
supports this legislation it's identical
to the house Bill 1319 so I'll say The
Identical thing which is essentially
that unfortunately as technology
advances people use that technology to
exploit others until the law catches up
this is an ability this is a a bill that
proactively addresses that and be happy
Police
go
ahead good afternoon Mr chair members of
the committee uh as well as the other
three individuals that have spoken
before me New Hampshire State Police is
also in support of this bill as we
werehouse Bill
1319 um my name is Lieutenant Tamar
Hester and I am a lieutenant in charge
of the special investigations unit in
the New Hampshire State Police we also
work very closely with the iak so this
Pro this proposed bill will amend and
expand the scope of the current statute
which will give law enforcement the
clear ability to enforce the sharing of
material in an online platform it's no
longer necessary to connect with
individuals in person in order to share
material it's as simple as a click of a
button to generate as well as share an
image across multiple platforms and from
there the image can be circulated around
the world with the advancement of the
digital age it created new forms of
harassment and cyber bullying since the
statute was enacted technology has
involved and currently there are
numerous software programs available
that can generate real realistic images
or videos that are virtually
indistinguishable from a real person
there have been many instances across
the country of individuals utilizing
artificial intelligence to create fake
pornographic images and share them
across multiple social media platforms
many of them in a fashion as which is
considered revenge
porn the sharing of an image that is
nearly indistinguishable from a real
person and shares the characteristics of
that real person can have a crippling
effect on that individual's life and
create a lasting stigma it is as it is
very difficult if not nearly impossible
to completely remove something from the
internet once it's been
distributed defendants are sometimes
able to avoid being criminally charged
by taking images of real individuals and
altering them in a computer generated
fashion to which it's no longer real
person and this statute will change that
this additional language will support
evolving technology and the ability for
individuals to quickly and easily
distribute images through social media
platforms as well as electronic service
providers we feel that as law
enforcement and government officials
it's our duty to seek as well as prevent
and get Justice for those who have been
sexually
exploited thank
you see no questions thank you for your
testimony thank you anyone else wishing
to testify in this bill who is not
testified already seeing none I hereby
close public hearing we will reconvene
sessions
e
where's my list okay I'm opening the
executive session on Senate Bill two
excuse me 482 and I recognize
motion thank you Mr chair I'd like to uh
make a motion a to pass for SB 482 now
second right would you like to speak to
your motion Mr chairman I would I think
this bill is uh definitely needed and
will fill the Gap that they're they're
feeling is an issue when it comes to
security clearances and evaluating who
should have them and who should not and
I don't think we should hamper and I
think we should assist them in uh making
it more
streamlined representative gather you
like speak to a second that was well
said Thank you any discussion um it was
pretty clear that U our our military
folks in the state need this so that
they can uh more quickly process people
through um right now they said they're
chasing down and fighting with people
trying to get records
um so if we can help them out let's help
them out any further discussion seeing
none I would ask the clerk to call the
pass Vice chair rhs yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative PR yes representative
janden yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balon yes representative Broadley yes
representative Duty yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Schultz yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair yes 20 20 the motion
about the pass carries any objection to
consent seeing none ofo consent I here I
session with that I open the executive
session on Senate Bill
415 and I recognize representative rhods
to make a motion thank you Mr chairman I
um move interim
study can I get a second second second
by representative appr would you like to
speak to your second excuse me at
first sure um there was uh several bills
that we heard that day a lot of them
kind of go around around and and touch
on the same subject um this particular
Bill if you look at line 19 on the first
page it talks about um quantity of five
grams or more including alternates and a
bunch of other words and it there is a
bill that is being heard in the Senate
right now that has a a higher amount
than that so
the thought was to interim study this
one and wait and see where it goes and
if we have to we can do something with
it over the
summer would you like to speak to your
second I'm in agreement uh with the uh
Senate Bill uh watching that and see
what happens and we'll have this as
backup further
discussion seeing none I ask clerk to
call the RO motion Mr chair oh I'm sorry
uh representative Muse yeah I I did I
did want to I I did want to note that um
one of the things that we didn't hear in
the testimony for this bill is that um
the there doesn't seem to be much
evidence that mandatory minimums of any
kind um really impact this this type of
behavior they feel good to do um uh but
uh I think that there's evidence that
shows they're not particularly
costeffective especially when you
consider that we can investing um uh in
actually helping law enforcement um uh
better enforce our existing laws you
know when it comes to to drugs as
opposed to incarcerating people um uh
for longer times our penalties in New
Hampshire are are quite severe for these
types of drug offenses so I I just
wanted to note that um that the uh the
idea of uh pushing this bill to interim
study isn't necessarily so we can pass
another bill uh with the same
issues thank you um further discussion
see none that asked the cl to call the
role motion to floor is interim study
Vice chair Roots yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative PR yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry GTH no
Balden
yes um representative Broadley no
representative
Duty no representative Newman no the
clerk votes yes representative Newell no
representative Schultz forgive me m mam
clerk but what is the bill number we're
voting on right now sp415 thank you I
vote
no uh representative wheeler n chairman
Roy chairl
chess um 12 to8 question of the chair
the motion was interim study correct
correct thank you uh 12 to8 the motion
of interim study carries who wants to do
the Minority
Report represent n is doing The Minority
Report who's going to do um who made
that when you
okay just for clarity I I'd like these
by notated in Tuesday
please um with that I close the
executive session I open the executive
session on Senate Bill 414 and I
recognize representative Stone to make a
motion thank you Mr chair I'd make a
motion on to pass SB
414 second seconded by representative
roads would you like to speak to your
motion uh Mr chair I would I think we've
heard enough in this committee on the
dangers in the uh life or death
situations occurring from fentanyl use
and I think it's a prudent thing to do
to have enhanced penalties for fentanyl
especially with death resulting in the
state we need to send a message that
we're not going to be tolerating uh the
drug dealing with involving fentanyl on
any level and I think this sends a good
message to
everyone thank you um representative bro
you like to speak a
discussion represented
Balden is anyone on the committee aware
of the penalty for penal possession how
compare stand by you have the bill do
yeah
so this is um with regard to if somebody
dies as a result of the dealing so this
is a minimum of 10 and up to life so
it's significantly stiffer than the
penalty for possession of Fenton itself
I believe it looks just a quick Google
it looks like it's three and a half to
seven years for possession I I guess I'm
just curious about that because I
question how many years someone needs to
face for their behavior to be changed
and whether or not there may be only
unintended consequences where we just
have people not calling 911 and cleaning
the scene as was
seen before New Hampshire started making
changes um I you know it's I just don't
know who's going to be arrested if no
one calls 911 and only a dead body is
found I'm not sure who we'd be punishing
victim
further discussion represent wheeler
thank you Mr chairman uh I voted against
inm study on the last one I'll vote
against the these mandatory minimum
bills very simply put because I believe
in judicial discretion I believe that
the judges don't and wouldn't
necessarily appreciate the legislature
telling them uh that we know better on
these issues and I think that when it
comes to their discretion to see a
person some people deserve High
sentences I think the Judge can
determine whether or not they do some
people might not uh and and I I like the
idea of leaving it up to the Judiciary
and I think the New Hampshire Judiciary
does a good job uh there so I'll be
voting against the a to pass motion and
I appreciate uh you letting me speak
thank you further discussion
representative
Muse I I do want to point out that under
our current law a judge has the
that comes before the court and and make
a decision under our current law I think
while doing something like this
maybe may make people feel better and
and I C certainly think that there
people feel extremely bad in this state
about where we are right now with fentel
I'm I'm just not sure how doing this and
making this change to our law would
really help uh address that
situation represent
newal thank you uh Mr chair and um I'll
keep it brief
um mostly for my own composure but as
the one person on this committee who has
lost someone to substance use disorder
who is actively trying to address it
while facing a 15-year mandatory
minimum I just I'm going to vote no
thank you represent
I just want to point out that there's a
big difference between supplying someone
with narcotics such as fentanyl that
results in death and vers in somebody
who's uh trying to get help for somebody
who has overdosed and that's where the
investigation needs to go and if the
prosecutors feel they have enough
evidence they'll bring it to the next
level which is a trial and if uh they
can't resolve it during a ple bargain
then it will go for a regular trial but
having a mandatory sentencing for
fentanyl for an enhanced penalty I think
is something we definitely need in this
state
representative
Balden it's odd to argue for uh
investigator discretion and against Pro
um Court discretion but I I just would
genuinely there's very solid Behavioral
Science to show that this will not
positively impact behavior in terms of
saving lives this will
most assuredly result in people in a
tough situation making the decision to
abandon an overdosing person who
has roughly 3 to five minutes before
brain damage sets in and not M much long
after before they are dead in these
moments when someone is
overdosing 911 needs to be called
immediately or the consequences can be
irreversible or it could lead to death
very quickly and if someone has in those
few minutes to decide between calling
911 or getting themselves in trouble I
would hate for this legislature to set
them up so that they're more likely to
avoid trouble than to save a life and I
would really hate for some sort
of partisan mindset or a desire for
people to work with certain team members
in the
legislature to be a driver for situation
in which 911 simply needs to be called
there have been many people in this
state who died of overdoses from trying
a drug the first time we're talking
about young people who tried something
for the first time didn't know what was
in it the person who gave it to them
didn't know what was in it why should
those people have to die because we want
to tell ourselves that we're going to
hold their hold the people who gave them
the drugs accountable and if we want
discretion in the investigative process
then we should also have discretion in
things representative
Stone I think this committee should be
well aware there's a difference between
the role of Judiciary and a role of the
executive branch I.E the police and
given that they each have a role to
fulfill and those roles are pretty
clearly
defined represent scitech I wish this
bill weren't
here um if we walk away from this
minimum which would probably be imposed
in any case we do we send the message
that well we walked away from enhanced
penalties or from this and I don't like
minimums I don't like this bill I I'll I
don't think I have a I'm G to vote for
it I'm not very happy about
it represent wheeler thank you Mr
chairman very quickly I just want to say
if this bill specifi
a an amount of fentanyl that was one
that only suppliers
and big manufacturers would be using
maybe I'd have a different opinion about
it but this bill doesn't specify a
limited amount it says any person who
manufactures sells or dispenses
Methamphetamine Lys surgic diamide not
going to use that word last word or PCP
uh and any other drugs in schedule one
or two would be sentenced to up to 10
years uh in for not less than 10 years
of imprisonment and I think that's too
far too too much uh for people that
might be just happen to have a baggie of
fentanyl because they're they're they're
drug addicted on the street um or they
might pass it off to a friend because
that's the the community that they're a
part of unfortunately um I don't think
those people should end up in prison for
10 years if we're talking about the
people who are trafficking fentanyl the
big manufacturers those people should
have penalties those people should never
see the light of day again what they're
doing to our communities is horrific but
what we're talking about is the people
who are being impacted by those people
and those individuals that are on the
ground who have done nothing more than
be in a bad place and get addicted to
drugs shouldn't be in prison
for at least 10 years that's that's too
much so thank you Mr chairman thank you
um I
as far as your point getting the the the
people higher up the way you get those
people is through information from
informance and the way you develop
informance is when they are facing a
stiff penalty in jail so you arrest
someone because someone died and they
gave them a small amount of Fentanyl and
they have a facing a 10-year minimum
mandatory they're going to be much more
cooperative and they can plead that down
and they don't have to do the 10 years
so there's there's different tools that
you can use and sometimes we even heard
during our bail hearings from someone
who is a convicted felon himself for
dealing drugs recommend to us you want
to fix this problem you need to bring
back minimum mandatories that's from uh
someone who actually has watched people
die and who actually helped people detox
in his own garage if I recall correctly
um so that people can um have different
opinions and come to different uh
results but the there there is something
to be said for both sides of the
argument um I think that we know where
everybody's you are you going to say
something different and it's not going
to be something about partisanship or
something okay go
ahead we also heard testimony from
people representing the recovery
Community professionals the recovery
Community people in recovery who argued
against this
legislation and and I think it's worth
reiterating that we don't need to be
discussing what the threat of jail time
will mean for someone one because I
guarantee you there will be people who
opt not to notify the authorities when
they've contributed to the death of
another the difference between a
mandatory minimum 10 and the
potential um time for possession alone
is so slim if they're already violating
the law against possession how is their
behavior going to be any different I
don't believe that this will motivate
anyone to call 911 and Save a Life I
think this will motivate people to leave
the scene we won't have people serving
mandatory minimum 10year sentences we'll
have more dead
bodies further seeing nothing else I'd
ask the court to call the RO motion of
floor is up to pass Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
citech representative PR yes
representative Jan yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tanzar yes Representative harri gther no
representative muse no representative
Balden no representative Bradley no
representative Duty no representative
Newman no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
Schultz no representative wheeler no
chairman Roy CH yes 10
10 1010 the motion fails um it it's open
for further motion representative
wheeler would you like Mr chairman I'd
move itl I have a
second represent Bradley representative
Bradley seconds motion is by
representative wheeler um would you like
to speak to your motion would you like
to speak to your second all right uh i'
ask the clerk to call the role the
motion is now inexpedient to
legislate Vice chair roads no
representative Pratt no representative
scitec representative PR no
representative Janan no representative
Manion no representative Reed no
representative Stone no Representative
on it is yes representative Muse yes
representative Balden yes representative
Bradley yes representative uh Duty yes
representative Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative Schultz yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
uh the chair votes
no um 101 1010 motion fails it will go
to the flow with no recommendation I
hearing again who's going to do the um
reports I made the motion I can do the
report okay report from you
representative Stone Again by Tuesday
please um with that I open the executive
session on House Bill 4 four and excuse
me
376 and I recognize representative Reed
to make a motion I motion o um to itl
can I have a
second would you like to speak to your
motion yes Mr chairman um the there's
are currently a pathway for um residents
of uh our Correctional institutions to
get get um to take college credits they
pay for them um so they they are
available
I just think um that um this is not an
ideal Pathway to a college degree and
should not be encouraged thank you like
second
um basically what representative Reed
said is what I would say I I do remember
that I asked some specific questions
about education that is currently
offered and I do believe that they went
into great detail about that that um and
the other question I that I had about it
was depending on um the length of a
sentence which I I think that should be
something that is you know that is
looked at and that was something that
didn't seem to even be a consideration
so um for that reason I would be
discussion repres wheer really quickly I
think the points brought are well put
I'm going to vote against OTP uh itl in
support of an interm study or an OTP
motion I think uh furthering the
commission for this isn't a bad thing
and uh the people on it are asking for
it so might as well allow them to thank
you um represent
Muse you we heard during testimony that
there there's actually Federal money on
the table that would do this um the
community college system supported it
the Department of Corrections supported
it um I think we should support it too
thank you uh representative Murray thank
you Mr chair um I agree with my
colleague representative Muse um this
bill was supported by the Department of
Corrections the community college system
um we have federal funds to fund this
program so it's not getting funded
through our uh State taxpayer dollars um
in addition this isn't about they not
being um programs currently in our
direct Department of Corrections for
college degrees it's about a Planning
Group that can better work with the
colleges to make sure that the programs
um and the whole system works adequately
and that we are offering a full range of
those programs and um I don't really
understand why this wouldn't be a way
that we would want to um encourage you
know better behavior in people like what
better way for someone to leave prison
than with an education that will help
them be an upstanding member of society
than you know just someone who's going
to leave in a worse position than they
entered um I think it's absolutely in
our best interest as a society to help
people develop themselves um in a
variety of ways um while incarcerated so
that we can reach our goal which is to
have a functioning Society with
everybody contributing what they need to
to be safe and
healthy thank you I I I guess I would
say why would someone incarcerated be
able to get a free degree that someone
who's out here not incarcerated working
for has to pay for that's that's where I
would have an issue representative Pro
you had your hand
up I'm wondering what happens when the
federal money runs out and then this
laws on the book that we have to give
them an
education I I don't know does anyone
have an
answer represent Marie has an answer I
mean again it's not a law this is not a
law in the books that we are like this
person has owed this specific program
this is just creating a Planning Group
that can maintain
a program of Education um while working
with the community colleges so there's
nothing that's like set in stone by this
bill that couldn't be um changed in the
future the funding um changed and I I do
know that came up in um in the testimony
as well I'm trying to find what the
answer to that
was um but if I find that I will answer
sure okay representative Reed thank you
Mr chairman they the the money the
Federal theel grant money that these um
inmates can can't access currently um
it's been my understanding that the the
college classes are available to people
currently and they are underutilized not
many um of the inmates do take advantage
of the opportunities provided to them
presently um the pel grants yes that
would be um would continue it's the
alliance grant money that potentially
would run out and that then would be on
the taxpayers to continue funding um and
also it is um
sends I think the wrong message to the
people who work um and pay their way
through college as opposed to um having
it handed to them um for
free represent Mur you had an answer on
the um yes thank you um basically along
the lines of what representative Reed
was saying um but that the grant funding
we have is just for the startup of the
program it's not in regards to any like
it's not the the grant funding is not
funding um the college programs
themselves it's just funding the
starting up of this program and the
setting it up so those fees actually
shouldn't be um reiterating as the
program goes on because the pel grants
will cover the actual funds that would
be needed um and in terms of saying that
um you know out outstanding citizens
aren't offered the same opportunity you
know pel grants obviously also are
available to people outside of prison
who um fall into the parameters required
they do as long as they don't make too
much money and if they work and they
have a job that pays reasonably well
they don't qualify for p grants but
anyone what yeah exactly um but if if
you're in prison you obviously qualify
because you don't make any money
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman um after looking over my notes
here on this bill I did point out to
Senator Waters when he was here line 18
page two uh says especially in
coordination with the England Board of
higher education and other departments
in correction with New England I I I
don't know what uh OS was doing that day
I know they're working very hard on 1,00
pieces of legislation but I don't think
that Senator Waters meant to have us in
coordination with any England Board of
higher education and I don't see an
amendment in front of me right now so I
I well that's true that is true that is
true you do never know I don't see an
amendment in front of me right now and I
don't know if I can support uh uh the
bill with the type with that typo in it
uh
I well I'll vote against it and then
support it when we have a FL Amendment
Mr chair may I ask what line is that
because in the bill I was given as the
18 page two line
18 ah you're right
sorry not to cast any dispersions on our
friends across the pond um
representative
new thank you Mr chair um we heard
testimony when we were talking about
um is it truth and sentencing and and
ways that people could reduce their
sentence right and what really stuck out
to me especially when we were uh talking
about this subject is the fact that um
there are certain things that you can do
to get yourself shorter time right um
and one of those things is going uh is
getting an education so if the
difference between somebody being able
to um have a lessened uh sentence or
anything like that um is is
financial that doesn't seem right to me
and then you know but then also um the
fact that uh the idea of having this
working group which is what the bill is
actually about right the idea of having
this working group to decide you know uh
how to go about it and work with
community colleges and all that kind of
stuff is the idea of saying okay
specifically for someone who is
incarcerated is something we know people
have uh trouble in uh employment after
incarceration for a variety of reasons
so what they're trying to do is say for
someone who is in this position what is
the best way what are the best courses
of action that we can take the best
courses um and programs that we can take
for somebody who is specifically in that
position to be able to succeed after um
they get out of prison so to me it it
makes perfect sense to have a group
which is what the bill is about to say
what actually works for this
situation
Representative no this a question for
the chair isn't there if a bill is
passed like this with a a type of G
graphical error in it can that not be
corrected after the bill is passed or
how it yeah a floor Amendment could
correct
it yeah
um yeah yeah thought they had more
latitude than that yeah we may with a
enroll bill it yeah yeah representative
boltman I just wanted note that
um there are many things that prisoners
receive that people um who aren't in
prison don't receive like Free Housing
free food and you know this this very
committee worked really hard to make
sure that they had uh open access to
menstrual products and clean underwear
uh without stains from other people's U
menstrual cycles on them and if we're
going to bother to pay to feed and uh
house and provide underwear and
menstrual pads for folks why not also
reform them in the
process I would retort that one is basic
human care and the other one is a bonus
that other people have to work to pay
for representative Manion did you have a
question oh okay represent Murray thank
you Mr chair um just continue to go
through my notes from the hearing but
Nicholas Duffy from the Department of
Corrections made sure to note that with
each um increase in a degree um in
education the level of reci recidivism
decreases so education provably reduces
crime um and then Mr Cher you had
actually asked if the program would end
up being um uh saving money for
taxpayers because educating folks and
preventing further crime and
incarceration is cheaper for the
taxpayer and Duffy said that that is
100% true and that they will have years
of Grant reports to prove the efficacy
of this program by the time um any
federal funds would run out um so
honestly in my opinion I would I would
really encourage my colleagues to
support this bill and if in the future
we feel the need to like remove this
program we can do that but we have the
money right now um and I don't
understand why we wouldn't want to take
every effort possible to reduce
recidivism and reduce the costs on
taxpayers through mass incarceration
when we have this option available um
for us basically for free because the
fedit I think I'm not sure but I think
the feds get the money from
us
okay um I don't think they just make it
up but um further
discussion see none uh the motion on the
floor is inexpedient to legislate I
would ask the clerk to call the role
Vice chair Road yes uh representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative
PR kind of on the line but I'm going to
vote Yes representative janr yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tzar yes representative
Harriet
GTH yeah no she needs representative
muse no representative Balon no
representative
Duty no uh representative Bradley no
representative Newman no the clerk votes
no representative Newall no
representative Schultz no representative
wheeler no uh chairman
Roy chair votes yes
1010 1010 motion fails motion uh bill is
open for further
motion point of order Mr chairman
yes if a vote fails 1010 do we have to
make the other vote in order for it to
be without recommendation or it's 10
tent yeah you have to exhaust the other
motions otherwise you haven't completed
to no
recommendation trust me I don't want to
keep reading these can we do what
Finance does and just do the hand thing
yeah I don't I don't think so I didn't
even know that they did that they
do B I'll make motion okay
representative n makes the motion of
ought to pass seconded by represent
Murray um discussion can I just say one
well first they get she get speak to her
motion do you want to speak yeah yeah
yeah what discussion well what I what I
didn't say last time CU I didn't think I
needed to I thought it was already said
but there was a very specific reason I
asked
about the length of the sentence because
if we are looking at Rehabilitation I
would understand that however to say
that to say that we have to do all of
these things to to help rehabilitate a
person I believe that all of us that we
here working on the bail bills all
summer we have we have said and done a
lot to show that we don't want to just
quote unquote throw people in jail um
and at the end of the day if you have a
victim that say they do have a college
degree and they are working diligently
to go to work every day and pay back
that loan but now they're looking at
default because of the the victim status
that they have where they are now not
able to continue to have that job how is
that fair to them right so for looking
at people when they're getting out of
jail that's not what this bill says so
if you have a person that is in jail for
a life
sentence to say that they're going to
have a better education than the person
that they victimized I I can't support
that and that is why I won't support the
opop pass
motion further discussion represent
Murray thank you Mr chair um I
definitely hear your concerns um Vice
chair um I think um in my mind um you
know when you brought that up to um I
think it was the individual from the
Department of Corrections you mentioned
that you know folks with a life sentence
would be at the back of the line um and
you know less likely to be able to take
advantage of those programs but
additionally I would say people usually
do have the option of parole so they
still have the chance of entering
Society and also you can even just think
of like the impact that has on their
fellow inmates if you have someone who's
like um a violent individual or an
unwell individual who can continue to
improve in prison like that person will
have an impact on the inmates around
them and um if you have someone like
that wreaking havoc in in prison that's
not going to have a positive benefit on
the rest of the incarcerated individuals
and could put them in a position where
they're going to come out even worse um
yeah there's so much to go into but I
just think that overall it's a benefit
to society as a whole to help everybody
become a better person um yeah that's
just my position thank you
representative Duty uh yes would it be
appropriate for me to make a comment uh
from the county
level okay thank you um I chair the
Hillsboro County um delegation and you
know we're actually uh in April we're
going to hopefully getting uh um a
document talking to us about the
planning for a new jail um because we
desperately need it and about two years
ago a year and a half ago we hired a new
superintendent uh for the Department of
Corrections who is very Progressive um
and you know uh so our vision is to
hopefully build you know a a new
Department of Corrections not a Valley
Street jail so that we can have all of
these Services um to to the individuals
uh recently we asked for a report in
terms of the number of days people
served in the um County Jail uh so I my
understanding by law is they can't serve
more than um they can't be in there more
than a year and a day and then they have
to go to the state prison you probably
know a lot more about this than I do but
I mean we have some people in the county
jail that have been there for like 2
three four years okay it is routine when
you look at um the amount of days that
they've been there that they've been
there for for nine months 11 months just
awaiting trial so I mean if if we can
look at things where we can take that
time and begin to have programs that
help them work on all of their issues
and get them to move forward I mean
that's clearly something that on the
county level you know that we want to do
so I just wanted to give you kind of
that
background thank you for sharing
representative Stone yeah just to
clarify this was geared toward Wards the
uh New Hampshire Department of
Corrections not any of the county
facilities since they all operate
independently and in your case where you
mentioned that a year in a day general
rule of thumb is uh most of your county
inmates are incarcerated for shorter
spans of time but your pre-trial inmates
that could be incarcerated there could
be a matter of years if they're facing a
nature any
further represent Mar sure anything else
okay representative har cther thank you
I just wanted to say and reiterate that
this is just this is a Planning Group a
planning committee so I think we need to
keep that in
mind I I I don't know if I
heard oh planning committee all right
thank you um with that I'll ask call the
rooll motion on the floor is now did we
change it where where are we all the
pass no I think I think right out the
pass Vice chair roads no representative
PR no representative scitec
representative PR no representative
Janan no representative Manion no
representative Reed no representative
Stone no Representative tenar no
representative Harry gright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balon yes representative Bradley yes
representative Duty yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes repres
representative Schultz yes
representative
wheeler yay but you should read your
bill before proposing
it chairman Roy chair votes chair votes
no 101 1010 um motion fails it will go
to the floor with no
recommendation and I close public
hearing who made the Motions on that
um representative nle and
representative cross motions um I need
the reports please by Tuesday
and what's
next with that I open the executive
session on Senate Bill
322 and I recognize representative Stone
to make a motion thank you Mr chair I'd
like to make a motion autop pass of SB
322 I'll second and that was seconded by
representative here gaite would you like
to speak to your motion represent Mr
chairman I would uh during our testimony
it was quite disturbing to think that a
chief of police which is usually whether
you're one horse town or a large agency
like Manchester has the Authority in the
duty to sign pistol permits in this
state as designated by law and that they
were some that felt they weren't obliged
to due to liability concerns the uh
Chiefs of police have the ability upon
application to run a uh criminal
background check to see suitability and
also have local contacts and if they
choose to deny it within 14 business
days under law they have the ability to
do so uh there is a mechanism to appeal
if you are denied to the district court
or circuit court now and it's just this
this needs to happen they need to take
their old serious they need to take
their job seriously they need to
complete it and sign these pistol
permits I can't imagine being out of
state one that we have reciprocity with
and handing them a blank pistol permit
filled out with my descriptors but yet
it says uh you know in compliance with
RSA 159 or it's just left blank I think
that's very problematic for anybody who
pays the fee to get the license which
they're not obligated to get any longer
and those fees should be noted they kept
in the local coffers they don't go to
the state unless it's a non-resident
permit representative here cther would
you like to speak your a second I agree
with my colleague but I also want to
mention that it was um approved by um
law enforcement as
well supported by law enforcement as
well thank you I I would just I I would
add to the discussion the fact that um
you don't need a p Department in New
Hampshire unless you're going to travel
um to go to another state for
reciprocity purposes so to deny a a
permit or to not sign it and let
somebody have to go off to another state
I just think
um but I'm going to be charitable and
assume that he really did worry about
liability and we've taken care of that
so let's pass it any further discussion
seeing none I last call the rooll the
motion is out to pass Vice chair roads
yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec representative PR
yes representative janen yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tzar yes representative
Harry gght yes representative Muse yes
representative Balden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Duty yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Schultz yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
chair yes 20 20 the motion of V to pass
carries unanimously any objection to
consent hearing none it'll go on consent
now hereby close the executive session
hereby open executive session on Senate
Bill 316 and I recognize representative
janver to make a motion Mr chairman I
move on to pass on Senate Bill 316
second seconded by representative Manion
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you uh as somebody who lives
in a town that borders um our neighbors
to the South uh I have perally
personally witnessed um trafficking into
the state of New Hampshire from that
Commonwealth and I've actually lost a
lot of
friends um and colleagues so I'd love to
see this
pass representative man you like to
speak to a second I think uh
representative jamman covet
it um I actually brought this exact bill
I think four years ago and um it it
didn't make it off the floor and I I
don't know if this one will either but I
support it just like I supported the one
I wrote which is
mysteriously exactly the same language
as this one but having said that
um my concern is
again we heard some discussion earlier
about the effect or non effective
minimum
mandatories and someone said something
about well if it was trafficking this is
trafficking these are people that are
bringing quantities of drugs into our
state that can only be for dealing it's
not personal use this is someone who
meets the threshold for dealing drugs
and they're coming from and we know this
we're coming from two specific places in
Massachusetts LEL and Lawrence the the
police departments have testified to it
it's on the record we know where they're
coming from it's a pipeline New York up
to there and then splits up and comes up
here they're bringing this poison into
our state and killing our children we
have to stop it somehow um if we could
um get the
people who are supplying large amounts
we heard testimony earlier about how you
know these are just um people who are
addicted and we don't want to send them
to jail because of their addiction well
these people that are doing this are the
ones who are pumping it into those
people so that's where I stand on this
bill this is after people who are
spreading this poison out and bringing
discussion
representa
M just like to say that in our current
statute um a person who actually
transports or uh or possesses with
intent to sell um can be sentenced to uh
imprisonment of not more than 30 years
um so you know again what I would say is
that currently our judicial system has
the discretion to apply an extremely
severe sentence to somebody who
transports uh these materials into New
Hampshire uh frankly
um I I understand uh why bills like this
are submitted but the reality is is that
to a large extent they're political
theater and they really won't help us
accomplish anything and uh and I wish we
could uh turn our attention towards
doing things that would actually help
solve the problem thanks I would respond
by saying that they're not political
theater and the people who propose them
think that they will help solve the
problem I would also submit that someone
who comes here and is arrested for um
possession intent is eligible for bail
and often times they make bail and we
never see them again because they're
either not from the state or not from
from this country and when they are here
arrested on being held on a minimum
mandatory they will not make bail and
they will stay and they will serve their
sentence and um and that's really the
thing is is we want people when they say
hey the these this fentel needs to be
moved up to Manchester today I want them
to look at each other and say no you go
no you go because I'm not going up there
because they'll put me away for at least
this long and that's what we want
discouragement um representative
read and then Stone um thank you Mr
chairman we had testimony from um a a
person who uh was trafficking drugs into
New Hampshire and he spent time in
federal prison for it and he said the
reason he came to New Hampshire was
because our drug laws were really LAX he
said that it was easier to go to New
Hampshire and make a lot of money
selling drugs here than it it was to
take a risk to go to Maine so to they he
saw us as a um lucrative place to sell
his drugs because of our um LAX laws
thank you yes I recall that testimony
thank you um representative Stone did
you have yes thank you Mr chair with
drug trafficking from out of state we
have a problem and we address drug
problems on many facets we hear about
harm reduction where we focus on the
users or the victims of the drug trade
but we have to have some accountability
for the individuals who are making the
money and profiting off the misery of
our citizens and what better way to do
it than to send a message that says that
if you get caught trafficking drugs into
the state you will be held accountable I
don't hear the word accountable very
much in this Committee just like I don't
hear and focus on the victims as much in
this committee and I often wonder why
that is since this is criminal justice
Safety representative new
Newman I'm having a lot of difficulty
trying to figure out all this talk about
trafficking and trying to get that to uh
based on the way the bill is written and
it says in addition to any other penalty
under this section that any person who
enters the state with any quality of a
fentol drug etc etc etc shall be guilty
of a class a felony I believe that's
that's holding people accountable with
class a felony and then it puts on a
mandatory five years in jail no matter
what the the the penalty was so I'm
having trouble with that didn't you any
the etc etc etc didn't it say say
something about what the intent to
distribute no I'm not sure that I
TR I don't see anything no I don't
reading it again read line four four
four it's on the fold tend to distribute
okay I'll have to just improve my
reading skills but it there is
accountability with the class a felony
represent Murray thank you Mr chair um
to be clear uh to my colleague
representative Newman the Class I felony
that's actually a new line in here cuz
the whole paragraph is new it's not like
the current yeah but um you just brought
up something that was my concern as well
was about the quantity but um I guess
with the intent to distribute would that
mean that there would also need to be
like other materials that are used for
distribute like extra baggies or
something like how do they prove that
yeah there has to be further indicia of
of dist intend to distribute um it's not
merely based on weight represent Stone
you compar to elaborate yeah I'd like to
point out also that uh it with our some
of our entities that do drug enforcement
in our state it's customarily to work
with the federal authorities in
sometimes cases we brought even though
they start out as a state case they'll
be brought as a federal case in which
the federal guidelines for asset
forfeiture kick in and sentencing so
perhaps in an example is say you're
trafficking drugs from Massachusetts and
you have a hidden compartment in your
motor vehicle where you have you've made
it that way and you have a concealed
firearm you will actually do more time
on the uh the firearm possession with
drug trafficking and your vehicle will
be
seized but but with regard to her
question about the in difference between
possession and P possession intent yeah
with intent generally you're looking at
uh I hate to say it but there's a lot of
times that individuals are targeted for
distribution that they know they're
under being watched and when they come
in they get picked off that's not
uncommon billing a case in addition if
you're caught with distribution such as
baggies or larger amount than what's
known as personal use for a reasonable
person uh if your your your packaging is
all individually it's kind of hard to
say it's personally use if you got 120
bags of fentanyl in your car there's
that and a lot of times what it is it'll
be a a control buy or buy bust so
they'll uh they'll have someone they'll
make several buys from that person and
then the they'll say okay I'm going down
to pick up another 50 grams or whatever
okay the third time they go to meet them
they trust them they come up they bust
them that time um that's where they get
the intent to distribute because they've
already distributed previously so it's
that's that's generally speaking how
that works and and what he said
regarding the um regarding the secret
compartments you'd be fascinated to see
the lengths and the money that these
cartels go to to build these into these
cars they take these vehicles to a a
shop and they literally tear them apart
and they build these things into the car
that you like have to stand on one foot
and pull your rear and pressure to get
these these compartments to open and
they're insulated so that dogs can't
smell they spend a lot of money on these
these hides when they come across these
state lines representative stone I'd
like to follow up with something you
said Mr chairman I've personally seen in
my own experience where individuals
cooperating with law enforcement have
actually traveled down under supervision
to the state of Massachusetts returned
to the state of New Hampshire where it
was orchestrated for the actual takedown
and arrest to occur and it's usually
coordinated with the outside agencies
and possibly DEA or someone else working
as a liaison so this is a common
practice so that if this did come
through we'd be able to have an enhanced
penalty for the drug trafficking after
the case has been
built he you had another question
represent yes thank you Mr chair um I'm
wishing I had brought an amendment to
this and maybe I will bring it to the
floor because yeah that specifically the
intent to distribute making sure that
that's clear maybe we add like uh
minimum quantity or something but the
other thing that I was thinking of is um
someone during testimony
um brought up the concern that if we
make it um you know at this mandatory
minimum for crossing the border then are
we increasing the risk that you know
someone picks up and moves their uh
operation from Lawrence to Salem OR you
know what I mean and just goes moves
right across the border in order to
avoid this um penalty extra penalty for
driving the the fenel across the border
and I would just be concerned about the
potential impact of like an increased um
you know more drug operations being
brought into the state in order to try
and avoid the travel
issue did you want to
answer unfortunately it's been a history
of New Hampshire that uh we're easy
pickings and a lot of times a lot of
efforts are are purposely directed
towards out ofate operations that do
come to smaller communities such as
mining clamont Newport um I'm sure in
your Manchester has them too these
people come here because it's such a
target-rich environment to sell product
and they can blend in pretty quick and
not be noticed for a while and the only
time you usually get those people is
when you get somebody on the hook and
you flip them and they go right up the
chain and usually you get the guy that
moved here from Massachusetts and
they'll tell you the story of how they
got
here and to your to specifically to your
question will that encourage them to
okay we're not going to do this state
lot anymore well at some point they got
to get here I mean it's got to come in
some way so if if even if they're going
to say we're going to shut up our
distribution shop in man in Hampshire to
get away from the crossing the they
still get across the border to get it
here so at some point they're going to
run into that minimum mandatory of
importing it for the intent to
distribute um representative Ro thank
you Mr
chairman so it's obviously not a secret
that fentol is coming up in this
committee I feel like it's every day at
this
point and it's also evident that these
drugs are doing irreversible harm to our
families it's eroding our
society it's creating
this awful division right here amongst
us and everybody thinks they have the
best way to solve this problem so we
admit that there clearly is a problem
so I can't think of of of a better
way to stop something than to have this
kind of a deterrent and what
representative Murray just said was well
is it going to make them you know not so
it here so it there I hope so I hope it
makes them not bring it back into New
Hampshire anymore I hope that that that
is you know the end result of it
um but but I feel like if we could did I
misunderstand what you said yeah oh I'm
I'm sorry well point is
is don't bring it don't bring it into
New Hampshire it's obviously what my
what my point is here but you know
during the testimony um there was a
representative said well it's to the
point where fentanyl is and everything
well if we know fentanyl's and
everything then we go back to this big
circle of well when then we have harm
reduction well do we need harm reduction
if we know it's in everything it this
endless circle of at some point we have
to do something to stop it we have to
and I feel like we've tried everything
else I just don't know what other option
we have at this
point and I apologize if I misunderstood
no it's all right she you kind of got
just a wrong State um represent Pro so
I've heard a lot about har reduction
right we want to do that the best way to
get harm reduction and stop it from
coming into the into the state right so
all our citizens are safe so if we have
to attack five years onto their sentence
to make them think twice about coming to
New Hampshire so be it they're not
victims they choose to distribute drugs
in our state nobody's forcing them
that's their choice and if they're going
to choose to come here and sell drugs
and bring it across the border then yeah
yeah they're going to pay for it and
then they won't be out for another extra
5 years bringing drugs
across I think I would add to that we've
um I I we have we've we've we're doing
kind of a carrot and stick thing here we
we have extended a lot of um help and
I'm sure we're going to extend more
towards the the addicted community and
and I agree that it's a disease and they
once you're hooked on this you can't
stop um you're sick and you can't you
got to get better but what we need to do
is we need and we haven't tried this yet
we've we've been dealing with this for a
decade now we need to do something to
stop the people who are bringing the
disease in um if while we're treating
the sick let's stop the
disease um I think we've beat this one
pretty good so I'm going to ask the cter
to call the role motion on the floor is
odd to pass Vice chair roads
representative PR yes representative
scitec representative pu yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenar yes representative Harry goth no
representative muse no representative
Balden no representative Bradley no
representative Duty no representative
Newman no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
Schultz no representative wheeler
hey chairman Roy CHS
1010 1010 motion fails open further the
motion representative here at G moves
seconds I did like an hour ago um who's
going to move second I represent n move
second
would you like to speak to your a motion
already okay um unless anyone has
anything further to add I'll ask her to
call the role please call the role Vice
chair FL in expedience to legisl Vice
chair Roes no representative Pratt no
representative scitec representative pu
no representative janen nay
representative Manion no representative
re no representative Stone absolutely
not Representative tenar no
representative har Gite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Duty yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Schultz yes representative wheeler yay
10 um chairman right chair votes no 10
times
1010 motion fails it goes without
recommendations to the floor um whoever
made the Motions please I need the
reports by Tuesday morning with that I
close the executive
session and we are done for the day yes
may I address the committee for one
second please go ahead uh look I know
we've talked a lot about drugs but what
I can't get out of my mind is what we
talked about earlier and that is to what
extent do we are we obligated either to
the incarcerated or to Society for
more is Our obligation what is right by
society and by the incarcerated and I
can't get that out of my mind
thanks thank you representative Muse um
would you like to make a a motion on any
morning give me a moment um yeah I'm
looking for a moment too so I can yeah
I'm going to open executive session on
464 yes I I would like to move interim
bill hold on a second um seconded uh
made by representative M seconded by
representative
Ro
U very quickly this bill is actually
duplicative of of a bill that we passed
earlier in the session uh unanimously
that actually went to consent uh that
bill is now in the hands of the Senate
uh and So to avoid having two bills
crossing over at the same time um I
recommend we interim study this bill uh
and if anything happens to the other
bill and the other body
um I'm not sure if we're still alive
here but um uh but hopefully um you know
we can do something with
it and who was your seconded that would
you like to speak to your second it was
already stated thank you thank you yeah
um whenever I see I just for the record
whenever I see a bill that looks exactly
like the bill I already heard um that
means I'm holding another
hearing um like the hearing I already
held I don't like doing that so I really
appreciate you making that motion
representative um any further
discussion representative jamman yes Mr
chairman uh because the pending motion
would be interim study when it comes to
the house floor I think we should table
it so that if the Senate doesn't act on
the bill that's before them we can pull
it off the table and and pass
it I would too but I wouldn't have said
it out loud
um but thanks anyway um with that ask
clerk to call the
rooll
Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative pu yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tensar yes
representative Harriet gther
representative Muse yes representative
Balon yes representative Bradley yes
representative Duty yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes yes
representative Schultz yes
representative wheeler chairman Roy CH
yes 20 20 of interim
study unanimous um any objection to
none again we're not saying that out
loud
say
e
I'm opening the executive session on
cill 313 we heard this spill this
morning um was regard to um the mimus
update so that the courts could send the
electronic the mimus through electronics
instead of paperwork um it's just
updating the system whenever a human
being changes hands like this who's
incarcerated or in custody they uh it's
done via
aimus um and it used to always have to
be a piece of paper well now they can do
it this way it'll save money and time so
I think we'll just go ahead and dispense
with this one so I'm going to move ought
to pass seconded by representative here
at GA um does anyone want to discuss
anything I said what I already good i'
asked the clerk to call the role the
Vice chair rhods yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative PR you beta
representative Janan yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenar yes representative har gther yes
representative
Muse yes representative Bon yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Duty yes representative
Newman yes CL votes yes representative
Newell yes representative Schultz yes
representative wheeler chairman Roy
chair yes 20 20 motion CES uh unanimous
any objection to consent none hereby
close executive session on 313 I hereby
open the executive session on SP 420 and
recognize representative wheeler to make
a motion Mr chairman I move a to
pass second by representative Murray
would you like to speak to your motion
uh very quickly Mr chairman I think
Senator Whitley did a good job this
morning um this study committee is on
the parole system we worked very
diligently over the fall uh I think that
there is more work I think
representative Reed said we had beat a
dead horse as much as we can but I think
the horse is still living unfortunately
um um so I just want to no I I agree it
is it's tough cuz we work so hard here
onal justice but we thanks now I have
the NRA and Peta after me me
too uh oh uh oh but I think that uh this
piece of paper needs to be beaten a
little more so and um I would like to
serve on that subcommittee again and I
would ask that everyone on the committee
please vote to extend this as the Senate
has thank you uh representative Murray
would you like to speak to your second I
agree with everything my colleague said
I also would like to continue beating
horses
thank you on behalf of horses everywhere
no horses were killed in the making of
this bill representative sitech I I
guess I I will vote for this even though
I don't believe in legislative study
committees
I well this one seems to have done
something so which is different I'm okay
representative uh Manion I agree I don't
believe in them if I'm not on
them yeah yeah that's about it all right
I ask cler col roll motion the floor is
out to pass Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative appr I think we
should Trot on along with this so yes
representative janr at the behest of the
equin society yes representative Manion
just a yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenai yes representative har ather yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Duty representative duty
is on the environment and agriculture
committee but she votes
yes uh representative Newman yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Schultz and they're
almost at the Finish Line yes
representative wheeler yeah and chairman
Roy you don't know how bad I want to
vote n but I'm going to say
[Laughter]
yes unanimous uh to pass um that I close
the executive session again if you made
a motion um and there will be a a piece
of paper going out an email later that
says about the report so I need them by
Tuesday morning so they can be in the
calendar representative new
Newman this is what happens when we have
a long session day followed by a Friday